welcome everybody to the h3 podcast here
with one of my idols a legend and I'm
honestly so honored and happy to have
you here you guys know him he doesn't
need an introduction
vivo living legend thanks so much thank
you bro
god bless it looking forward to this
thanks man actually is really hard
we're here with Gila Cline the original
Gila kleiner obviously I my phone is
making noises and that is just [ __ ]
and I'm you so let's dive right into it
so you know a plate one sec mute it up
also I need to [ __ ] out for one second
Oh [ __ ] away really just like five
second okay cool to then this feels like
and thank you to our spawn on Abels no
audible good night today so movies
people get them I was back in that [ __ ]
because got audible that day I'm back in
whatever you I'm gonna be like I'm gonna
expect a check from audible now it's
actually our sponsors today are equipped
Rick weak and black tux and we'll get
more into that a little bit later black
tux oh yeah boy what about your purple
text node is black text cell purple they
do I just had a better way to go pink
there yep [ __ ] go you know that I was
back in you so what's up man would even
up to these days I've been up to I've
been pretty quiet on the social media
for the last week or so as I've hunkered
down and worked furiously on a new video
project yeah user lurk and we get a
little sneak peek yeah well it's um a
rough draft so to speak of what will be
my next stand-up comedy special own
which is a multimedia extravaganza
packed with an anton's a bonanza yeah oh
smoke right yeah it's just a while back
and notice I thought you know as I was
performing one that but you know the
stories I'm telling are largely [ __ ]
that happened on camera so what if my
next comedy special if I edited in the
archival footage of and so just like I
want crazy about it I've been hunkered
down that's so cool
yeah can you go look right because it's
the thing is that like it like when I'm
doing the show as sometimes I just can't
get
past thinking there's no way that
anybody in the audience believes right
not only is what I'm saying true but
that it's actually like there's like an
attention to detail of the truth you
know can't believe it I don't think
anybody would because such outlandish
[ __ ] but it's completely true and so
then when when I put this together and I
just think I've been going through all
this footage that she's never even
appeared anywhere and it's like you know
at a great show right and I'm just blown
away did I buy how much there is to back
it up and then on top of that I've been
I shouldn't probably say this because we
don't have any kind of an agreement but
we've been like loosely discussing the
the director of Jackass directing and
producing this and and and sort of doing
like really heavy
Marky's stunts which I would do for a
jackass for there is no jackass for so
like I'm to be huge where he's like the
big like things and then we've dropped
them into throughout the comedy special
as it is yet so wait let me so you're
going to do new stunts on video to show
during the show like what to edit and we
drop in vignettes right but I want to
make them pertinent like like I'll go
ahead and I'll just exclusive for you oh
[ __ ] my idea for the opening sequence of
this this extravaganza this bonanza I've
never seen they've got a traveling
billboards which big basically is just a
flatbed truck a big a big flatbed truck
in the middle of the flatbed is just a
gigantic billboard I see them saying
like gays are going to hell and [ __ ] I I
have not seen that somebody would not
say I've only seen them driving around
Vegas okay but a nanteos and at any rate
and they drive around and they promote
what everyone promote and so the idea
for the the opening sequence is to have
one of these travelling billboards
promoting the live show itself with the
billboard in LA we get up there and we
just duct tape my ass to mostly vogue
billboard itself okay
Doug take me to the Billboard and once
I'm properly duct-taped we get on the
road and we drive way to Vegas duct tape
to the doors for the entire five hour
drive there's a lot of bugs on that way
that's fine print really bring it you
covered and did but bring it out and I
want to join it and then as we drive
down and I picture like like dough above
dope time-lapse with like you know the
you see the sun's up when we start but
the time on to the Sun going down at one
point like a van is I will pull up and
be pacing alongside in the highway and
the door slide open we got all the
Jackass guys in there shoot
like shooting paintball guns at me from
the moving van sounds desperate bill
that they don't know they'll really pull
over and paste like right next we know
and I want them to actually jump out of
the van onto the flatbed so they can
more personally torture me as we drive
down the highway and then of course
we'll get to Vegas we'll go down the
Sunset Strip as the opening credits
you know the whole like the whole
opening sequence comes to we plot the
theater this show takes place in Vegas
oh that's [ __ ] and so then and said
that I'm going to do it I'm not come
except yeah what was i bad no cover to
bugs and like burn I think I [ __ ] air
we REM kind of film all of the
interstitial vignettes and opening
sequence the end what end I think is
going to be a really massive deal in
like the theater maybe a vignette
outside but but in any case I'm just
thrilled that I'm so excited about it
that smells absolutely Nana I'm there
exactly am a good job that is going to
be huge all of the like all of the ideas
for the the really big stunts are major
and even the stand-up you just can't
ever be left without like mind-blowing
footage this cut into it so it's just
like a kind of a docu comedy marriage of
my two world it sounds really cool I
mean I don't really creative and
different okay that's it has to be in a
world saturated with with comedies with
so much competition you guys it like
Netflix and so until next year Netflix
has like a heavy heavy hitter every week
I've noticed with like with Dave
Chappelle you got Seinfeld Chris Rock
like I mean all the like Ellen you
should be like really really big no so
so I like the idea of you know from the
director of Jackass you know like just
Marge is crazier than the next like a
level of crazy and really more people in
with all of the jackassery I'm genuinely
when I'm over when they get there with
the stand-up genuinely excited we're
going to the show oh [ __ ] I would love
to have you guys there I love it but let
let lets stop with all the ocean no it
is promotional or man appreciate that I
mean like when I first met you for the
first time you guys I didn't realize
that you were doing stand-up wow I got
that Darius how's that going look it's
been so great man I I need never
occurred to me to do stand-up even
though I'm an all-around attention [ __ ]
so it makes sense right
alright but the first time it came up
was that was 11 years ago almost 11
years ago for a while right it was um
there's a comedian named Skyler Stone
and he I didn't know who he was at the
time but he reached out to me he said
that he was hosting a show at the
world-famous Laugh Factory on the Sunset
Strip in Hollywood California and would
I come and and get on stage during his
show and perform crazy stunts as I'll of
course again I was out of my mind over
you guys do hybl come I didn't give it a
thought I was just there doing drugs and
I didn't care as a guy yeah for sure and
I showed up I'll just figure out when I
get there and when I walked into that
comedy club again summer of 2006 I
believe it was August maybe I walked in
there and and I just looked at the stage
and as like so that's what they do here
it's terrifying and I just immediately
it occurred to me
there's no crazier stunt and I could
come up with then third hand there and
do that [ __ ] oh yeah so I was like oh my
god to do that I'm gonna do that and and
I was like I waited for my turn to get
on stage as
and I've sent around the book well what
I'm saying ultimately I don't think I
was on stage more than like three
minutes I said it feels like I've never
I gotten stage I was like hey everybody
I'm in the mood for a [ __ ] system
does anybody want oh yeah look on the
spot it was something that I came up
with while sitting there waiting for my
turn to get should write a nice wit go
some way right unlike Sir Lancelot
good what I watched the tons of yeah I
decided their own twist twist their way
right but in any case up maybe the
overall experience was and real at a
real sense that people were excited to
see me
they were and they were rooting for me
to do well yeah how was it exceptional
McCleary I was only on stage of
agreement I got a couple laughs people
are excited to see me I felt like
they're rooting for me and I was like
man this is what I wanted I want to get
into this and I was still out of my mind
on drugs it took a while before I really
got serious about it but but yeah 2010 I
don't man full oh [ __ ] you been are you
serious my definitely holy I've been
touring I've been trying for a tree on
my seven years he's a veteran but now I
feel like it I've made some progress I
feel like it's a little bit of an uphill
battle my reputation will never be for
stand-up comedy because you know I do
all this is about enough but was what
was had said with that said I come to
the table with a built-in audience he's
interested in and you know and and my
experience is so much what drives the
stand-up that's just like you know you
don't have to really believe I was he
can be good at stand-up it's like all
that motherfucker's crazy let's go
Simran oh yeah yeah instead think dad's
mad more and I take it seriously I
really do care about about what I do and
you know I keep the people laughing and
and like I'm super grateful for it man
it's been going to going very well I can
tell you as someone whose call me on
YouTube
I dream of doing stand-up and building
here I mentioned it when Moe had your
your crisis yes I feel like I was a part
of yeah yeah zero no I was a part of the
crisis near like [ __ ] and I just shot
was way too much for for you too bad
when we cut your nuts off right yeah
straight of poor steve-o but like the
thought of going on stage is truly
horrifying to me in the beginning it is
in the beginning it is but pretty
quickly you you through experience
figure out what is working for you and
what isn't right and then and then you
kind of you develop your comfort zone
where it was where even if you're if
you're trying something new and it's
going terribly you know you've got stuff
that is proven to work with this
material yeah right so once once you're
into honing stuff and we've got like and
you've got reliable stuff it's going to
go well you can fall back on it gets a
lot easier to venture out of their
comfort zone because you're gonna call I
tried something [ __ ] didn't work okay
and then I bring it bring out a hammer
how's the feeling of like being up on
stage and feeling like because I've
heard it described it's like being
empowering right like empowers I guess I
mean I think that the reality is that
there's there's something dark about
comedians in general like anybody who's
inclined to get on stage and like just
desperate for validation and like please
please clap for me please like there's
something that I think is inherently
involved self-hatred on some level do
you feel like you have to get on stage
and really just be so desperate for
attention and approval I think that's a
good now the same with art to
representing in any I mean and as a
society we've become such attention
[ __ ] I feel like I always look a
little bit ahead of the curve but uh but
whatever man it's all good and touring
must be pretty difficult to write oh my
god that's got to be the worst yeah as
we thought about doing a live tour
recently we've been just a neighbor to
be so proud it would be a great I'm sure
would be a great experience we're in the
pre
very stage of planning it director
delicious no they're like okay we're
going to take you on the road for two
months and you're doing six shows a week
I'm like I'm not thinking about this
right I was like man I can handle that
the comedy club circuit which is which
is the majority of my tour
now obviously eaters here and there and
if I'm going international it's all
theaters but or music menus sometimes
internationally is that because their
age is good I don't know I guess they
don't have comedy clubs or uh but the
way that the comedy club scene works in
the u.s. I I go out on Wednesday saw
dude Thursday morning press I do one
show on Thursday I do two shows on all
the same club I go for five days to
11.00 that one place I got one show
Thursday two shows Friday two shows
Saturday and possibly one show on Sunday
so it's either five or six shows in the
same venue all in one weekend so when
you do two shows it looks like I've
gotten to a point where I'm like I'll
just genuinely dread I just judges ready
because not only do I do the whole live
show immediately afterwards I take Jamie
agree between higher audience I promise
every single person wants a photo as
much as you love your fans that's got to
be really exhausting because it's like
gnarly it's gnarly it's hair that you
did the meeting greed is a is harder
work than the show it will happen I do
whole show a holding be a whole show and
a whole new group that's so something
that really scares me about it is that
you have to repeat the same show
it's what scares you but cuz that's like
we always do every week or every day's
we do something completely new right we
always move forward with right you're
free people getting forward or just like
we got our own experience and being like
stuck on great like you're in the loop I
got to understand why it's in the same
on the day yeah do you ever feel that's
something I thought about what comedians
it might not be at all that bad it's
just bad yeah yes yes it sucks and at
the same time
it you can't you can't perform that many
shows without improvement you know even
if you try to dear you know even if you
try to do the same show you know even if
you can still you're good it's kind of
evolved it's not evolving and as you get
kind of the bigger picture process is
you know you go everywhere I don't ever
want to go back to a place that I've
been before until I have a new show and
so you kind of go everywhere that you're
going to go you'd be bring to be
burnable you know like the crowd is
different and good right so you do your
whole circuit and then you tape comedy
special and then and then when once you
take the comedy special then you start
really doing new material but your video
you have until the special airs to kind
of do half an arrow and fall back on
happened so then you develop it and then
they could start over again it's
absolutely different multi guys so
that's also one of the reasons I'm like
concert' or like hesitant to try to get
into it it's like I've gone good at what
I do right and I know that it over
lately it's like starting all over you
in terms of skill set and understanding
right it's so funny I mean I think that
where you're at with stand-up is where
I'm at with the podcast you know I
really think because I've I've had this
idea to do a podcast for for however
long and I've had like the you know the
reps setting it up negotiating and no
deal has really been finalized there's
been something holding it up or the
insurance you know feel you looking to
get cuz you just [ __ ] they going get
some mics oh god low rider don't
reservist Claudia well yeah I mean and
it's not like there's really that much
money especially if you're just starting
it yeah but but I don't know it's
thinking when you have like the
sophisticated representations the
big-time agents and lawyers it just
serves to slow everything down yeah it
does it serves to slow everything down
and and and I have actually in the
podcast arena welcomed that because I
have kind of cold feet the way you do is
tandem
- that's like Oh of the insurance on
riot yeah Simon meanwhile I'm happy to
go on on other people's podcast and it's
crazy like I like I have been able to go
in some really big ones uh yeah you've
been on Joe Rogan several times all
right I have like really notably twice I
would say because the first timer tear
that I did it there was just such a room
full of people and I was really uh it
was really kind of early in my process
of the comedy from the very first times
and so I was kind of sure that I just
wasn't but but the last two times on Joe
Rogan has been really just me in him and
and then I've gotten more feedback from
those podcasts then like even being on
Howard Stern or anything like that it's
just it's incredible what a [ __ ]
badass Gerald actually yeah he's
fascinating a guy is incredible one of
them's like a and I can tell I was
telling him like what a fan I was and I
could see him get uncomfortable just
friends yeah you know and I'm like yeah
wow like I just love it man that like I
follow him on Instagram and his post he
always has like this really long
explanation of literally fascinating it
kind of makes me angry I'm like why is
this guy so [ __ ] more interesting than
me like he puts his time and to learn
like a dedicates himself because his
that I'm like dude he's the back patio
games and let's give you some credit
though man I mean we should dive right
into this cuz this is what I like this
blanket definitely the dad now that our
relationship began and people did
probably all know this so even though
there were articles written about it was
there whatever articles written about it
about how I tweeted a one night I was
fascinated about some topic or rather
whatever it might have been and involved
it involved individuals faking pranks to
get into that and I was like and I was
like man because I was like that as I
guess is interested like I get away with
it you know it's just like someone I was
thinking about it I kind of really get
away with it and so I've started to like
researching a little bit I want and
the rabbit hole where I was no longer
even focused on the initial subject I
was interested in and now I was on to
this this this Joey salad guy another
golden moment oh my god and then that
was I think my first video I watched
which will have tailors then the one
with him or not at first I watched the
one with the man in a black lives matter
and then and then when I watched you
when you interviewed him not the whole
saga Choji I get I guess I got part one
Angela children Jesus that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] is amazing and and so then I just
started watching wonderin it's the
middle of the night when this is all
going on I I have been like 3:00 in the
morning and I'm just watching Age 3
video after HD just respond just go down
the rabbit hole and I just and and and
then and this is coming from absolutely
no idea said I just heard of you for the
first time and I just watched video
after video after video and then I got I
got a [ __ ]
I got a do something with these guys
yeah I got G something with these guys
and so then I tweeted at you yeah and
for whatever was a thing I had said I
don't only just now became aware of
introductions kind of got it so I can do
something yeah well I thought that I was
like [ __ ] this let's go yeah right
idiot Lee within 24 hours I was at your
house five hours after that sweet we
were on the phone yeah and you gotta
have R at like 11 you were when surfing
or somebody surfing like a real badass
oh [ __ ] it was like that like a real
badass I came back from the beach and
we're hanging out it was great it said
Jeff you remember the topic of our
conversation when you came out oh I do I
remember quite a few topic we we got
into some great stuff because he gave
Frank's is close to my heart that's yes
I write I do what I do I was like dude
Chuck and you guys are like the [ __ ]
internet police you know you better
watch out like ah oh my god and the
latest magic get off of fake pranks we
will certainly go there but but this
latest did
I guess I give those subconscious on
it's time to stop Lent
sing one cuz why might never faked
anything so then I'm not worried about
that but uh but what was it like I tried
a [ __ ] vine star you know like which
called scare sketch the integrand
Instagram comedy
yeah Instagram college as I said was I
saw your collab with Viners right I do
too yeah I did two of them and the first
one ah the first one was an idea I was
sitting on to the longest time I was
like man you know like a bathroom
etiquette thing and I was like like
right up there it is what yeah exactly
here is my premise and it's really
[ __ ] funny is that if if a guy
heaven forbid comes out of the bathroom
and he has left the toilet seat up
a woman's you know likely yell at him
mom you're so rude you left the toilet
seat up right Pizza but were they what
they don't [ __ ]
consider is that the reason why the 12-2
is up is because the guy was polite
enough to not piss her up and not piss
all over in the front that [ __ ] - right
it's like oh oh let me let me let me be
thoughtful and let me not piss all over
the toilets I'm going to lift it up to
make sure I don't piss on I don't want
to sit my piss that guy gets yelled at
but then the other guy who leaves it
down piss on it and gets and gets get
showered with praise yeah that's a great
thing so how did you trends well we made
like I got together with some finer and
I walked animatic any nobody bowlers
lately
oh not not the biggest one okay not big
one you have like the broke-ass weird
Viners you know why I where I got
recognizable but you don't know from
where you know I was watching it because
we were playing to the video on
Instagram video Instagram comedian
so specifically Viner I figure on so I
was watching everything well I haven't
seen yours Bob there's a lot to get
through
but the thing was are what I put when I
posted that one the bathroom one it was
still the most viewed thing I've ever
put on Instagram
Wow I guess yeah
done some outrageous [ __ ] and and then
the sketch and I thought man I got to
really get into this wait a my second my
second one what a camera Leon you uh
wait what
it's just on you I've seen in the chat
and we're just saying the cameras on
illa they were demand was anything what
you're not the director dammit what the
camera blues song ring I know how long
was it on how long was it on you HeLa
what let's get the camera back on Yellin
and no interfere money like no Diana in
case they said that was a ghetto self
purchase on your last alright then the
land physics is like I bet I got into
the impact I comedy look nobody'll bet I
saw some good stuff there
yeah yeah yes generally these Viners the
supremacy of these whiners dis max
exodus from vine when it got closed down
and they're like these parasites like a
dystopia there int they're like well
getting all the social media should be
fair that Exodus occurred before vine we
let but that well because they were like
wow you know we can have longer format
so it's like Roy it's like World War two
the Jews were they were sprinkling out
but once that right Holocaust said then
you're like oh [ __ ] just fighting
everywhere do you really have to be
Jewish say that you do it help yeah
after that help and it's just like that
yeah yeah so said it was the fake pranks
business god I've been so ah
so well you have a history with these
guys some of the guys we've spoke about
a lot but Ali right Roman Atwood one
who's there the other ones those are the
big boys these guys that help me launch
my youtube channel this was crazy
because you know like with the Jackass
franchise I was a part of three
theatrical box-office movies you know
and all of them were number one you know
they were made with like notoriously low
budgets and the profit margins on the
Jackass movies were astronomical
it's just like you know I even heard
that paramount was like in real trouble
at one point and and is it a jackass
movie this I mean it's probably an
overstatement to say that we saved them
but we certainly helped I might really
have a question yeah I'm not asking to
say how much but like I know you guys
famously got paid like very little for
the first episode or the first movie
first movie um
the yep the I think what I mean I know
that I got like 65 thousand bucks a lot
of movie me but there are a lot of
quotes goodbye there guys good exposure
a lot of guys get exposure and I would I
would have taken that and been like oh
my god let me read like the first the
first season of the TV show I got paid
not even per episode I got paid per bit
and if it wasn't perfect cut your bed
out you don't get paid right I gave it
up that's going to put up there like
pariah and if it was if it was really
high impact like dangerous physical no
no stunts success I got 500 bucks per
bed no way that's it it was like super
dangerous look you had like a 10% chance
of dying in a spin I'm going to kick you
a couple hundred extra bucks right well
if it was uh if there's like a sight gag
you know like a low-impact Commodore
you're not in danger then there's 200
bucks
that is honestly [ __ ] off and because
they're they're promoting you they're
encouraging guys to endanger yourselves
yeah of course that's right I'll stop
saying dude by the thing is an event
while on the front door like do please
don't cut me even with that even with
that and it's come to my attention more
like it because i i've looked at dead
someone's deal someone who's just
starting out and they've just got such a
[ __ ] shitty deal that ties them up for
so long and and i look back on like our
contract for that first season didn't
automatically renew itself you know i
wasn't like in it and I think that Noxon
and true man really protected us from
that and and not to a particular with
the movies and when it came to that
first movie apparently from what I
understand he just said
I'm not [ __ ] doing anything I'm not
getting in front of a camera unless all
the guys have back-end so while we got
well we got to see the 65 grand or
that's what I got maybe then I go you
did have a back-end crap Oh for sure
what did you write yeah what a G it
wasn't like big if you know it was it
wasn't it was they might even be aware
of that right well happily get [ __ ]
over right and so so you know all all
things considered it all worked out
pretty well there was the first season
of the TV show at the end of the day I
made less than 1500 bucks and I think
they still air I think it's still out
there almost right and the reason I
asked about your mind is because I I
think I saw you say this quote yeah I
think of it and it was NH captivated me
you said something how you are super
famous but broke and I never sat around
can't imagine I would have said that I
was broke that time when the famous but
not rich that was right right right
right and I was like damn that's kind of
funny
if there was a quote it would have been
some of the effect of it's a lot easier
to get famous than it is to get rich I
think that's probably why do I feel like
you were broke in the early days why I
don't leave Airy famous I've not been
broke and when jackass first came out I
was certainly broke because I got so
little for that first season I'd been
kicked out of my there were my sister's
house where I lived she kicked me out I
was fired from my job I was a circus
clown so when I have to hit like that
when jackass started when Jack has
started to air when it being when it was
in permanent premiere on MTV I was
unemployed homeless and broke work alone
at a star we're actually over you were a
previous class I was veteran circus
clown yeah but I was unemployed and I
had no money and I was no place to live
so and you were super famous but it all
hit pretty quickly and and people would
recognize me and ask me for a picture
and autographs and I'd be like yeah sure
like can I sleep on yourself can you
right so that that I don't know that
concept to me is really fascinating yeah
combination yeah and then within two
weeks by the first episode aired one
week later the second one and then when
we captured at the third so when they
got the ratings back for the third
episode I got a call from the executive
producer who said it's officials where
the highest-rated show is kind of format
and in like the history of MTV I mean
obviously not higher ratings and then
the VMAs or insights but have any kind
of half-hour comedy like theirs they'd
never seen a bigger profit margin and
and and then I was in a contractor I was
in a position to renegotiate because
because I didn't have a contract that
tied me up and I would credit Knoxville
with that and instead okay so we know we
got to pay you for the MTV just ordered
seasons two and three Wow in the same
time is the first season with eight
episodes right so that said they ordered
60 episodes okay you know like as
seasons two and three together they they
got into this by of 16 episodes night so
we know we got a page we're going to
give you $2,000 per episode and in my
mind they buck using what and in my mind
I was I wasn't even like I didn't occur
to me that the first answer is always no
no matter what it is no matter was your
first thing there's no temptation or
anything advice yeah the first answer is
always no that's just what you do like I
guess I don't I didn't know that oh
we've been through the same [ __ ] yeah
you know so in my mind I'm thinking wow
okay so 16 episodes times mm that's
$32,000 I'm [ __ ] rich is that like
what Ana and I remember - this is
[ __ ] cool time and I mean I didn't
yeah I didn't care man I didn't think I
was going to live man what I was sure
that was going to be dead so soon you
know like and I remember they started
filming the you know for uh pretty Craig
I would film in short bursts man that
whole first season of Jackass I filmed
in the space of five days died only
fellow Leland I only found on three of
those did
well then I the first trip yes it makes
sense above the 30 mm I guess after
taxes is more like 20,000 yeah and then
they gave me half of that largely
upfront and I am remembered I called up
Jeffrey and I was like dude I just got a
check for all right now and I didn't
just get it so I'm about to get a check
for $10,000
I said I've never even heard of $10,000
I said I'm just going to put it to you
like this when I get this check it's
going in the bank and before that
[ __ ] even clears I'm going to be
on the road driving from where I lived
in Florida to LA I'm driving a truck in
LA I'm moving to California more [ __ ]
pub pop off of this [ __ ] you know your
dream to move to LA pretty much my life
is an agonizing wait to move to LA you
know across the board everything I was
ever into is from out you know
heavy metal music skateboarding like
stunts like you know yes I was a huge
gold and beautiful opportunity I was so
great
I was represented all the opportunity
yeah and the dopest thing was there when
I told that to Tremaine you said if he
said hey click and you're not going
anywhere until you give me a list of
ideas for jackass stunts in every single
state like give me something give me
something for every state between
Florida and California Aaron and if the
list rules out then I'll send out a TV
production crew to follow you as you
drive across country and so that's who
we did yeah it was awesome and I was
like what I think I'll kill it you went
into the show yeah for sure
so I got away a head start and I
remember by yourself during those those
well what the producers rode with me in
my car and then alleged production team
followed behind seven years man it took
like five days to get across country and
I remember I was like I was like okay so
I'm going to be in Alabama I was like
Alabama
he said the deep south I want to go to
like a black fraternity house at a you
know college campus I just want to show
up unannounced and bang on their door
and tell them how impressed I am by the
by their brands you see like black
fraternity guys they've got these crazy
brands you know from branding their
flesh with hot irons and I want to print
like a
like a brand like Grammys branding
branding flesh with hot iron and write a
brand to people you do that yeah they
still do it you see their guys arms and
it's all it's called keloid when when
the scar is raised up and they get their
their fraternity all right [ __ ] logo
like whatever they're the Greek letter
like yes so they're all rockin yeah mr.
vegetable out I wanted my skin to be
[ __ ] branded okay and I was and I was
going to tell them out of respect for
your fraternity I don't wanna I don't
wanna I'm not a member of returns I
don't want to get your fraternity logo
whatever it is I want to get a heart the
shape of a heart branded over my heart
as a metaphor to show that love hurts
Wow yeah very real it writes out a
wonderful thought that was I wasn't mind
my ideas didn't get branded well yeah
but the thing was that then when they
said to submit all the ideas so they'd
submit the ideas they came back they got
to approve them and maybe they said okay
with you can't get brand Billy we can
get branded as if it's by a professional
everything had to be under the
supervision of professionals so it's
like okay
it sound like a an in Alabama a tattoo
shop where they said okay we can be
branding they didn't really do it but
maybe a professional said AIDS watch yes
I got branded oh my good thinkin so yeah
oh that better to look like when you
first did it I was 16 years ago they're
very subtle just white heart right yeah
I don't I don't have that a skin that
scars that great that's right up join me
at arena I feel like I got gypped
because if that is good right okay
you're slamming baby right but I'm but
then when when when in some didn't
they've submitted the footage then the
the standards and practices the TV
censors came back and said oh well we
said you get steve-o branded we never
say anything about airing on television
footage of sizzling smoking flesh right
I ended up I got kind of branded for
nothing which welcome it's a reminded
yourself that love hurts it's true you
know sure of that lesson but yeah so
that's how it all worked and then I got
out to
I got out to LA and [ __ ] man I was March
of 2001 man long time I didn't find out
how fast you can spend $10,000 what the
thing was that uh that I got a call from
this guy like he was like hey man um
just before I left Florida this guy dug
me up because we were like really
popular on MTV with the first season and
he was like hey man I'm calling you from
Cleveland this guy was a rave promoter
from Cleveland and he says I'm having a
party on a party and I think it was
January 25th and I want to fly you out
to attend this party and I'll get you
out the next morning we won't even be
gone for 24 hours and I'll and I'll pay
you 700 bucks and I was like dude don't
just give me 700 bucks I'll [ __ ] chew
and swallow glass I will run myself I'll
lay myself on [ __ ] fire
I'll write my [ __ ] head on fire you
overvaluing seven is nothing right
turned out that everyone out there and
it was me wee man and bam we each got
700 bucks and that doesn't mean that's
the first time I ever first time BAM
ever took ecstasy Craig David Tom okay
like I got two pills and I broke one and
a half and I just gave BAM a little baby
half and I took one and a half yeah and
and bad was like oh my god Kim what he
took one of these you know like rolling
on oh dude he was rolling on a half an e
I was tired taking one and a half I've
done [ __ ] meth mushrooms you looking
better ugh that was gnarly
yeah I was so gnarly and so hey but I
remembered distinctly that I did end up
getting to sleep so what are they ghosts
on boy I fell asleep because I meant
because it's the same guy the promoter
the next day yeah he was like hey your
flight leaves like in an hour I was like
underneath his dining room table like
he's like in flight leaves
Howard he won't even try another god I
just went in the blend all day that's
wonderful shouting run run run bother
then I slept all day under the guys
table and then when I woke up like we
walked across this bridge in Cleveland
to this restaurant and it visited the
Cleveland River and it was January so
I'm walking across I looked down and the
river was partially frozen and in
certain areas and riots some others like
theirs were like frosty and dry you know
but I could see it was like shitty
advice you know like sin yeah and I was
like - I'm not leaving Cleveland until I
get a [ __ ] pair of ice skates and I
go skating on that River until I fall
through so I fall through the ice
what was it inside of you where it seems
like back then it's like everything you
looked at you're like I need this is a
challenge - got to prove my shopping
yeah I was like and I was never in it
for the money man like I said I didn't
think I was going to live very long I'd
such a terrible drug problem you know I
was just like I was just like whatever
man like what was it though that I don't
know I wanted to be remembered forever
you know just saw every opportunity to
get out there I just want yeah I just
wanted to [ __ ] be loved and important
somehow you know and remember that like
we're all going to be dead and I was
like I want to I want to live on after
I'm gone I want to still have I want to
have a legacy that's that I saw to do it
right but this guy I was in Cleveland
for a week you know before I felt do
dies twice I wasn't happy with the
footage his first time so when I did it
in the shooter shorts it didn't it just
didn't work for me so then I went back
and did it in a tutu and that day we
filmed it better so so over the course
that we can in Cleveland like this guy
real obliga he had made $35,000 on his
party he just flew you guys out just to
be there just to be there was a great
era generator
yeah is like a and this was before like
the whole personal parents thing was
even really a leg d9 I need 35 grand
just from riding large sport you think
having you guys there promoting an NBA
and for sure we were big stars you know
and a number two he was like he said on
may wonder when
I miss that flight when I got up he's
like sewage so when you got to give me
home he's thinking that like I'm a star
and the biggest show on MTV and life is
I got [ __ ] to do this again the party
was January 25th and and so he says when
do I get to get home and I was like oh
well kind of into this chick and I
really want to be home by Valentine's
Day what some [ __ ] is going on here and
uh and he and he was like I had been
whoring myself out to this Internet
company for like 500 bucks a bit for
Internet codes and so he was like well
what about what are you doing for money
and I was like dude you kidding me I
have like I bet I was like I have like
1,200 bucks in the bank like you know a
grown-ass man loved it like right right
and uh didn't have a club he was just a
promoter okay but I got it it is so
funny and and that guy I he pitched us
and the sort of public of personal
appearances for a spring break oh and
Panama City
so he's like I gave me three grand circa
think of it was three grand for two
weekends oh my god quite a lot more than
right right right
and sadly got to the point where it was
like three but the thing was the first
public appearance
yeah the personal appearance thing was
at the largest nightclub in the US and
it was sort of a meet and greet kinda
thing we're supposed to be there we're
supposed to appear but as I was there
there was a [ __ ] stage and I was like
there's a dense stage over there I'm
getting on it and I'm like I got on the
stage and like thousands of people came
over and I'm like Jake like go go go
give me this give me that and I'm like
they're on my fire the birth of the one
induced and uh well it was certainly the
birth of a tour perfect full circle
beautiful stuff right there well yeah
what happens like I got on a stage and I
kept people at that stage like like over
a thousand people for over an hour they
gave me a microphone and I was like
doing like my fire-breathing acrobatics
like nut cakes and like this
and I kept doing all this crazy [ __ ]
like cutting myself at the light bulb
and cheering and swallowing the glass
like all my [ __ ] and and the Cleveland
guy was like dude we got to show you
know we're going to show and in town so
we just said turned into a whole world
tour and really it wasn't stand-up as
much as more like nutty I did I promise
I will be drunk and on drugs or your
money back
that's my guarantee for every show that
was my guarantee man Cultra
steve-o must do right high it was never
in writing was never in writing but but
I held up my end of the bargain
yeah you're you know you're a loyal
performer right and uh it is great it
wasn't it wasn't stand-up per se but but
it was certainly a lot of performance
and you know hi how do you look back on
those days do you look at those like
Iolaus or you're like [ __ ] up
it's great yeah everything about it was
great man like this is [ __ ] up for
like a sober guy you know I've been
sober for a long time now but but I
think to myself man if I could repeat
like six six months window of my life to
just live on a loop that's like the the
first six months of 2003
well we're [ __ ] gnarly you know it's
about to get to okay because you were
never should have a car honey right you
had a little you had enough money where
you're like oh I have money I have
freedom I didn't know I had enough money
I but I didn't even have an ATM card
I had no ATM card I didn't give a [ __ ]
ah it was just like this this guy became
my Sh'ma shady
[ __ ] commander the Cleveland dude and
and I started like distributing my DVDs
not paying me anything I can salsa right
I saw your merch at your stores and I
could not just selling merch at my shows
and I don't think I ever got a penny
from merged
you're selling pre-cut is convolute I
had I had a I had a [ __ ] late-night
TV commercial support firm for my too
hot for TV
stiva video DVD it was why it was like
ah man ah a beginning because that's how
it happened whether it was Tremaine when
Tremaine first told me that
jaga's pilot got ordered he said so so
so didn't like write ideas for when we
come to smell me in Florida and take all
the video but if you haven't send it in
so we can license it onto the show and
like a week later it told me that not
one clip I sent him was was allowed on
TV says unfortunately nothing cleared
standards and practices what I was like
I thought a what kind of a [ __ ]
watered-down [ __ ] show are we going
to make they've been turns out they just
had like they're really particular about
fire and it's because of the beavers and
blood back and and and and another story
I've heard about it's a spiritual axiom
then whatever you do is cooler if you
are on fire yeah okay so if you guys
don't know this was a huge hiding back
in the day right this animated show
beavis and butt-head which is really
revolutionary at the time it wasn't it
was great it was a wonderful and and
then periodically and regularly yeah
Beavis would click lighter and go fire
fire fire I remember when I was a kid
everyone was walking around doing be
with somebody impressions it was huge
and then a kid burned because I got in a
trailer park a kid was playing with
matches or lighter said the whole
trailer and fire killed his baby sister
and TV was held liable for so that's
like yeah it was just the one of the
first instances of like there's words of
censorship of like this whole thing like
our video games principal for violence
like I don't know the high traffic what
a great question but it's like I want
you to always manual for joking I don't
think yeah I want I watching this
documentary on airplane and the title of
it was our video games really that bad
and I watched the whole thing and and I
turned it into a joke which I never
really used but they didn't what this
documentary
revealed is that there is no link
between video game violence and real
life violence right but there is however
a link between playing video games all
the time and being a complete [ __ ]
loser
yeah yeah we don't need a document
that's like the strong wind is very
strong causal relations and I said that
on up that's a great bit you should take
those I said that off the the game
grumps vodka these guys they play video
games you know this good those guys are
[ __ ] awesome I don't know I actually
never met them but I gotta give props to
those dudes and there's another one
where I have an original price man how
do they sell out comedy clubs and they
just go play video games em yeah I know
I felt like it's basically a podcast set
to the visual of a video game right and
I went in there and said I want to play
the most violent [ __ ] videos if I
don't want to play like jackass the
video games yeah I was like now dude
I want the most [ __ ] gratuitously
violent [ __ ] would what should I
forget what is even called but it was
beers pretty gnarly
I'm hilarious hilarious um well we're
selling it through and do this oh yeah
let's say we'll take a quick break how
about that that was a great I was a
beautiful thing Stevo you're fascinating
ah thanks I apologize many buddies
hurting in these stores before I keep it
pretty fresh you know but you know what
[ __ ] dude she got the first half of
this podcasters down second half of me
has it been an hour yeah that's been a
no always just slam it did oh my god
you're like button on this guy's I know
I know there's no like button but like
met like mentally if you can smash it
right there's a like button this is one
images oh my god they're going to be
full rockin we were talking about how
likes are the currency of the future
right you nobody makes money on on
YouTube anymore we all just come for the
likes that's right as a validation man
that's all that matters
so we'll take a quick break I got it I'm
going to talk about some sponsors who
make this show possible cool and cool
cool but if you won you can go to
bathroom just a head start okay god
bless you
so when I get back I'm gonna [ __ ]
crush guys our sponsors make this show
possible
I actually the sponsored parts are kind
of fun for me yeah better kind of I've
been learning about really interesting
products they're actually useful
we said that we feel like we're
and Shark Tank says seriously I always
look at these product because I'm always
looking for interesting products that
can like improve my life because you go
to Rob's or some [ __ ] or Target you
don't always find like the interesting
[ __ ] that's out there everything's on
the internet I don't know what's on the
Internet is too big
here's one we got this one is called
quit okay where's my quit brush so this
is an electric toothbrush called quit
and this one the invention of the year
actually was that [ __ ] rim invention
of the Year by Time magazine 2016 that's
what it's kind of so let me close the
door I'm hearing myself so this
toothbrush starts at 25 bucks and it's
electric I don't think it I don't think
you need to charge it or even put a
battery in it and what's dope is you
push the button it vibrates and then it
keeps track of your brushing - so every
minute it gives you our 30 seconds it
gives you a little vibrate and it turns
off after three minutes it helps you to
keep track of your brush and it's
actually I'm obsessed with oral hygiene
what do you think Ethan actually really
is it says I'm a [ __ ] brushes for an
hour sometimes it's not that long
sometimes I brush so long I like urine
right now like a whole episode if we
watch the show you'll find the whole
time which is probably 30 minutes yeah
sometimes I leave the toothbrush in my
mouth so long that I like where it burns
my mouth do it but I'm obsessed with
oral hygiene grow up bad breath and bad
like mouth [ __ ] just is the biggest
turnoff ever and - there's actually
results for you because whenever we'll
go to the dentist I have nothing to do
anything nothing I do just brush your
teeth for 30 minutes the fifth is I
don't know how you do it so this guy's
quit you go to get quit calm for / h 3g
t q-- u i p comp board / h3 you can get
this starting at $25 i used it right
before the show and it's it actually
works amazingly it gives you that like
sometimes i brush and you stuff like
schmutz kind of like you can feel it
yeah so with this i didn't have any
yeah and I'm always looking for a good
toothbrush when you go to the store
they're always like too hard
you notice that I tell me about it I'm
always on a constant look for the
softest too fresh also this is good I
mean I honestly I'm going to use this I
think it's a great out of their
toothpaste starts at 25 bucks new brush
included free shipping included go to
get quip dot-com for slash h3 help the
show support it this is a great
toothbrush I'm going to use this me too
let's go how is that you guys buying
this toothbrush anything else to say
about this it's actually legit and for
the for the price of 25 it's a great
deal I wanted to do the link in the chat
but I on the phone is so hard yeah that
that's the sound of clean teeth ye
oh cool snipers got it a pleasure thanks
Doug yes Pam that Lincoln Chuck get
clipped calm what a great was Denny's
noises let me check to make sure that
works so that's our first sponsor and
these sponsors really are the [ __ ] this
show won't be possible with other sport
we have a ton of expenses here and
they've graciously supporting us and I
wouldn't I wouldn't bring a product I
didn't believe in this is actually a
really great toothbrush and then I think
the best part is that it keeps track of
it for you it kind of motivates you I
don't have that problem at Liz Brice for
three minute it goes for three minutes
and then it turns off automatically and
I'm really good have it yeah promotes
you to [ __ ] clean that dirty mouth
this link isn't working it's not working
huh get clipped off or /hd it is not
working what the hell are you seriously
we seriously crash their website
you guys weren't ready for this [ __ ] get
quit time to get some more bandwidth on
your server we just crashed our sponsors
website that's very funny
I guess that's a good thing / well age
three right core man will [ __ ] there's
bocce tqu IP complex issue it's the best
spot for them and their websites
completely crashing hopefully
down there quit hmm this isn't the first
their first rodeo
well anyway hopefully hopefully people
will be able to visit that on YouTube
okay I'm finished the copy right I'm
chord the last bit of the pot and I was
like [ __ ] man like I'm finishing off
then I took a sip it's [ __ ] like cold
what it's both not like a hot iron oh
sorry yeah what the hell do you compose
you get the coffee hot I think I got him
you know what the [ __ ] sorry dad don't
blame me
oh you want you want me to nominate
Congress yeah my job I'll make a whole
conference is that okay
no I want more too that was I really
enjoyed that cup some reason got me
right well I got another spot do you
want to do that wine you want me to go
in follow I did shoe if I can keep the
pace em I felt like we were on a horse
women baby
I wish land I have anymore just spot to
do here I'm just like [ __ ] man let's
let's keep defining of kids and chest
and let's keep the crazy oh um keep
coming hello slow slow like a roulade do
you mean like they watch they tune and
no it's up and slow so no no it's been
done to this point but I'm worried about
did ahem we this release okay we're
alone everyone else
we've lost 9% of our viewers no we
haven't
we got to keep the juice flowing we got
to keep the you know got to keep the
money flowing right gotta get paid or
you getting played you know about that
that's right dude so here let's move on
for this one though that I just took
that piss as I just felt like I was
pissing money she said it's the best
part about this show man she join me
when I go to the bathroom so I can who
can piss money together although I
technically you're not but right man
I'll give you like 5 smear day like this
all right let's do this last one real
quick so this one is called a week winc
wink and they have this service where
they give you four bottles of wine every
month and the really cool thing is I
like wine but I don't know how to choose
one you go to the store there's like a
hundreds of bottles I don't know what
any of it means you you you know you
take your chances sometimes it's good
sometimes it's bad so what's interesting
about this service wink dot-com or
actually that is get wink calm four
slash h3 I can't believe you left me in
the trenches Oh God try wink calm Ford /
h3 try that's t ry winc calm for / h3o
quip is up again this is such a [ __ ]
show so this wine company you take a
quiz and you answer like 10 to 20
questions kind of ask you some general
stuff like do you like nutty you like
nutty flavors do you like acid eat
flavors right and so based on your
preference they send you four bottles
every month and we tried before we got
and it's really fun because it's like a
nice variety you really left me in the
trenches here you look we're getting
creamed dude you [ __ ] that we're
getting creamed out here I'm talking
about we [ __ ] times up so they send you
four balls and it's a really nice
variety so if you like wine I do enjoy
drinking wine you get like all kinds of
different little treats was to white to
red you get to choose it what you like
how did you enjoy the wine Allah I
actually really like this the molbeck
sick demo back was my favorite he was
like let's [ __ ] get all this I'm just
so impressed by you guys really yeah
you're doing this looking like it's just
great man we all link is down people are
saying wink is down I can't handle this
are you serious hold on I mean I got to
see if this is real or not
try wink comm h3 if this is down I'm
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] my pants and scream
it's down what the hell's going on
why was was crashing because that means
we refreshed their compassion because
we're crushing it hit the crash you were
crushing but it
I don't know if that's probably well
they can't it's a crash to crashing yeah
there's a good Christian graduation they
can't blame us for the Christian rabbi
yeah it actually works it's very slow
okay so weak word try wing works
apparently they said whip is up if you
guys are interested in that toothbrush
offer can you spam that can we get some
spam on the clip
we got the wink now we need the clip
sniper can you come anyway got office
would then you go to wink and go to wink
comm trust you go to try wink calm /h
three you get twenty bucks off your
first order de beach if you order now
and free shipping try Winx comm / h3 the
bottle start at 13 / pop which is a
really terrific deal if you guys know
anything about wine because apparently
it's more expensive than that usually
how about the how about that fur is
going so bad man I could like it then
but uh I like it okay
okay we got it guys we got toothbrushes
we got wine thank you so much to our
sponsors of endow sound interesting it
would mean a lot to us if you go try
their product it helps support us a lot
how do we do that I screwing those up am
i [ __ ] no my fire I only care you know
though let me plug it so why your help
hearing your expectations are too hot
for the shows do it all it's a non so
just train wreck I just I just love like
the idea of like when whenever ah
whenever I'm in the or thought well yeah
yeah focus and people's attention I just
want to [ __ ] hammer time I want to be
[ __ ] awesome the whole time is you're
all you because I'm doing will get
access so when we get RUP I've just got
an open mic huh I'll get it women why oh
you're done if you want it can you want
to solo time okay why they honored you
want to do I want to be I want be on
okay so here's what we're doing we're
not taking a break I'm gonna go to you
want this to be part of the show or you
want to just entertain do you want us
off the record on the wreck I'm giving
you all options whatever you want where
there's any such thing is killing me to
to but having to jump with us all yep
also if you want I can let you like look
at
chatting you can talk to them so I'm
gonna roll it I get that comment I'm
gonna roll out a little bit of a delay
so they hear you so much diva they're
[ __ ] they want it they want my eyes
out okay they're begging for it okay
give it 60 seconds because I need you
doing how many people do we have okay
hold on I'm Anna rola this is the talk
about pissing on the red carpet although
I did piss on the red carpet I'm rolling
this sad sad if I can you have two
minutes where half the people can see
you half can umm two minutes where half
the people here we have can't why are we
[ __ ] half the people when taking half
the people and just [ __ ] that you're
off okay
alright I'll be back soon yeah okay let
me think here like I would I could
respond to peeing in the red carpet was
pretty
remember when you died that was funny
man did you guys have mean people to of
course you do ignore those right and I
watch them reacting to negative comments
with with Ethan's parents okay so now
what what can I say I'm so impressed
with with Ethan and ela I really really
am and it's good that they're out of the
room while while while I kiss their
butts a little bit when we did that that
YouTube video where we cut my balls off
it's incredible how much [ __ ] response
there was and here's Ireland you know we
talked about all likes and I complained
about how my following my YouTube buzz
like there's stingy with the likes and
this and that like um [ __ ] I just want
to give it give it up to you guys for
being such dope fans of h3 and and if
you're fans of mine and show that love
if you happen to be in Denver or Tempe
Arizona which is adjacent to Phoenix I
will be in your your spots coming up
first week of July in Denver second week
of July in Tempe so now
for that gratuitous plug I should I
should cough up something on I should
cough up something something salacious
and juicy hmm hmm pissing on the red
carpet but I'm still thinking about that
it is so dark and depressing like when
we finish making jackass 2 and this is
going back what 11 years now [ __ ] it's
about 11 years and uh that movie was
that that right there is the best
jackass movie no question like a certain
jackass 3 made a lot more money and it
was good it's great and had the phantom
camera with the super slow-mo and nobody
had even seen that before the technology
with the 3d and the super slow-mo made
jackass 3d very special but the
masterpiece was jackass number two that
second movie was masterpiece and when it
came out I thought my life came to an
end I was like you know what no matter
what I do after this point nothing is
ever going to be as big of a deal
nothing's ever going to be as badass
nothing's going to ever be so impressive
and so the rest of my life is just going
to be just a downward depressing [ __ ]
slide towards oblivion and I showed up
that premiere for that that second
jackass movie was just this dark [ __ ]
my life is over and I was so mad at that
red carpet because it represented like
the end of my [ __ ] livelihood it
represented like the peak from which
everything was going to be downhill and
I was just so mad at it and I pulled out
my dick and I pissed all over it right
in front of my four-year-old niece she
was four at the time and standing out on
the red carpet watching me piss with my
dick and my dad was like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and I told my dad
goddamnit dad is my red carpet I'll piss
on it if I want
Oh excellent I'm crashing I'll be back I
think it's a pretty engaging story that
I'm telling and if there isn't moral to
it
what yeah of course if there's a moral
to it I think that it's important that
we be careful about passing judgment on
ours Joe Rogan told me I want to said
man I feel I'll never outdo my first
podcaster the last one I did he said you
don't ever try to compete with yourself
you know ah yeah now there's been 11
years since that second jackass movie
[ __ ] man
like not everything I've done has been
bigger they're better or more impressive
but but [ __ ] I have grown up man I no
longer feel like I'm going to be dead
imminently
you know I learned how to dare look back
and back then man I was so [ __ ]
douchey not that I'm not douchey now but
[ __ ] I've grown up so much and then so
many ways have improved so much and I've
learned I think I think I can say that
I've learned that the even if the
popularity of of steve-o is not not what
it used to be that that doesn't mean
that my life is miserable oh you're
[ __ ] metonic off you know I'm a ton
of cotton out there yeah
right right and and I'm just expressing
gratitude for you guys for you guys I am
I'm so impressed with you guys I'm going
to think about it because I'm talking to
a million people right now if they're if
I'm not talking to a million people
right now I'm still talking to a million
people yeah [ __ ] million people
listen to this I'm back for the one okay
good so now we're now is now so it's the
feat shot damn you know what you're
doing there's like at least 10 guys
jerking off at your feet right yeah
I don't know I didn't just want you to
be aware of that I think it's pretty
dope now I
and I be maybe one of them like I had a
special a special little solo time with
the audience there's how I thought it up
this is one advice start with a lot of
gratitude and butt-kissing towards you
guys
thank you okay when I went into I went
into somebody mentioned this red carpet
and pissing on it and I really I really
pulled back the layers of the philosophy
and the dark depression and I culminated
in an N hopeful message what was it what
I wanted to like really repurchase I
will go back and watch that guy's number
two I felt like was our masterpiece and
that when it came out I was ago my the
rest of my life is downhill from there
so you felt I did and I want to shut up
at that at that premiere I was just mad
at the red carpet I was like this red
carpet just signifies and my peeking out
point where everything's downhill if you
feel that way I don't know I was just
like I understand the feeling I think we
can ever outdo that I got that all good
so big it was so good and so big there
was never supposed to be another movie
after that successful it was depressing
yeah because how do you fall I just like
I can never I could never be it's like
when people win the Olympics bro you
know when people win a medley like I
know a bunch of people from having gone
to the University of Miami Oriole
Olympic athletes Briley's Olympic
hopefuls
and I train their whole life for it now
the the only thing it took a one of my
best friends
Brian Gillooly this guy won like ten
consecutive junior national titles are
never going to be outdone and and when
when he turned 18 he went to his first
senior nationals qualified first place
won first place Brian Galloway 18 years
old senior national diving champion
before scores ribbon up they knew
erupted so hard and and that was in 1994
however the Atlanta Olympics were in 96
so he went full scholarship to the
University of Miami in in 1994 and met
me right and like we know sorry I met
him in 95 I met him in 95 and mostly in
96 we really broke down and he just
became a rock star man he was the
[ __ ] full scholarship
I'm team universe suntan you he's the
guy on the view now started partying so
I can he did it and make the Olympic
student he got at Olympic Trials and in
Atlanta he got the best dive of the day
he was not one of the two people that
went to go dive on the 10-meter
and so it was like this incredible
career and you would think that was the
most upset of him the most upsetting
thing that could ever happen to train
your whole life in the Olympics and then
not go when in fact what proved to be
the worst thing was our buddy Scott
Dhoni who did go to Atlanta and he got a
[ __ ] medal and then there it was and
when they put that metal they [ __ ] I
was like they hung the end of his life
around a Phoenix that's what it is only
try that's the moral of story they put
in every track where it's a mirror from
zero just given I mean dude I got goose
bumps man like the idea of like they
pushing a medal around if you had a
horrifying thing it's like it's like
here you go I'm hanging this medal
around your neck like it's all downhill
from here nothing will ever be that I
don't like that you'll never leave
pessimistic what I can to kind of s is
mine but I understand our homeboy Scott
Dhoni lost his [ __ ] mind
my homeboy Brian Galilee is the head
coach of the University of Florida dive
team so I can he's great man I just
talked to another days guy he's got a
girlfriend he loves and we both have
like healthy relationships now and like
so it didn't cross looking back like
when you were on the red carpet and
you're like it's all don't matter what I
might get I was pissing with my dick on
the red carpet in front of my
four-year-old niece here who came out
was my sister and my dad my dad's like
we bring your family or did you know you
were going to do that was like a
specialized in say with my family I've
always been there like us I'm done with
this to like I know Steve well I mean my
dad was like what do you do my dad was
shocked and appalled and a fellow that's
fun
that's a fair they say it's like I said
what the [ __ ] you doing here hit me so
what you doing I said dad it's my red
carpet I'll piss on it if I want you
know the bless went out of control man
so so right I'm like I like I like
you've got this like healthy kind of
mentality and you're just like wait wait
like achievement like so you don't see
that you know you're just not programmed
that way
like I don't know if I look - oh it's in
there when you have for example it's not
even close to confined to that but like
for example when we had like a really
big video go viral all of a sudden and
then we had that feeling of like how do
you make the next really right oh
definitely I like subpar we've been
there I'll never make a video as good as
this yeah but it doesn't really
discourage me so much I don't know it's
like friend it's a different thing
because on YouTube it's like you just
keep chugging right and this is this is
literally no more jackass right this is
the hopeful you know one of my solo time
and I brought it to like this hopeful
message because you know and look like I
was 11 years ago and and and you know
[ __ ] like how much have I done that was
that bigger impressive you know like I
could like in the guards in a downhill
slide but but over the last 11 years
I've grown up in a lot of meaningful
ways right
like I've become a much better person
like overall I like I have grown as a
person and so it is important to just
like proverbial speaking there's more
achievements right then just like maybe
an attention whoring then I mean that's
and one that's like this way to look at
it I'm a professional attention [ __ ]
are we all right in a way and I don't
think of that as a bad thing but just
like I think I'm a good attention [ __ ]
you're a great one I'm good at writing
on Clark as I love and I love when
you're looking for my attention it's
like oh man I want I want to wash
through with this guy's up to iron the
worst ones are the ones from like I
don't want to watch this but I but
they're in my [ __ ] face right that
was the best you're right you're one of
the good I think that like I pride
myself in particularly with podcasts for
for being a pretty strong podcast guess
I think when people say ah Steve as I
know I kind of dude it's going to be
dealt well first of all you [ __ ] you've
probably seen and done more [ __ ] than
almost everybody who's ever lived well I
appreciate that I mean you just have had
such an interesting life I'm good I
don't litter it about about making [ __ ]
notable over the years so let's bash on
some people let's [ __ ]
let's let them have it so okay cool a
die we got Jack a little bit and the
beginner talking about how when Stevo
came over to our house for the first
time right we're talking a genetics
right right and and I typed I told you I
told you a story and you were like oh my
god said on my podcast now I don't want
to [ __ ] burn any bridges you know I
will just say I'm not gonna bend you're
you're not very thick fine I just got
I'll say this but there are some some
YouTube personalities at one point that
I was trying to make a video with and
words a tall order hairdo and and
they're like oh whoa what would do this
we'll just fake it and I was like good
what I was like what the NNI was and I
was like stop I got serious and I was
like look let's be [ __ ] very clear
like if I fake one [ __ ] thing if I go
and put out one [ __ ] thing and then to
be clear by definition this presumes to
be real right cuz you can put things
that is mostly big nothing yeah it's one
it's when you're trying to pull the wool
over your viewers eyes are deceiving
your audience exactly by presenting
something as real when it is not and if
I said if I do that so much is one
[ __ ] time then everything I've ever
done in my career will come into class
or intelligence that was super great
thought everything I've ever done and
I'm waiting about faking prank system so
you had only went so hard and you know
like I've cared so much about my legacy
had cared so much about about my art yes
that to have everything come into
question there's just no [ __ ] away I was
like I said this is like and it think
that without me like having to name
names I think that with your help
particularly you guys that anybody who's
out there and thought that they could
get away with presenting things as real
which were not have subsequently been
[ __ ] out it I think they you can't
get away with that absolutely and they
were getting away with it for the
longest time right started doing YouTube
videos
nobody was watching us for like year
yeah
and all the [ __ ] that was super popular
at that time when we first thought about
doing YouTube was pranks that was like
the huge thing on YouTube at that time
and they were all just fake not only
were they fake they were super toxic
they were all like pranks in the hood or
gold digger prank right where they're
like the world is ugly and it's a [ __ ]
up place and black people are violent
and women are just money hungry it's
like really not right like they're kinda
headed right that wasn't an accurate
restaurant so was not only just fake for
me that was only a part of it
but it really pissed me off was like-
baby that the world is like yeah like
words matter types yeah right no that
was the [ __ ] that really said me I think
that like looking back I've read some
articles they're evidence from whatever
I seen some stuff talking about about
like the sort of YouTube prank
you know phenomena or whatever and how
like they really in some of the cases
just totally missed the mark and had and
I've seen people compared to jackass
where they all even just say like oh my
god I'm tremendously proud of the
Jackass legacy in that we were never
mean-spirited you know my hard luck in
love though target we target ourselves
and we would have used people but we
would never target people in a mean way
and that's so common that's why you guys
were so inspiring right I think that we
were role models only in a weird way
[ __ ] maniacs absolutely crazy [ __ ]
maniac self-destructive like you know
arguably [ __ ] not a good influence
but we were not the spirit of what we
were doing was was so uplifting really I
mean look I've lived with rage of a
couple of kids having fun we would not
mean two people and I think that that
head of everything to do with like that
you know I could cross that line and I
certainly have I had plenty but but the
creators of Jack Houston where Spike
Jonze um that [ __ ] I John him so much
every man johnny Knoxville and they're
like creative visions they may just so
presented of like wait hold on that's
dark you know that buddy that's dark or
that's me
and like and they just kept it really
you know and I just really rad back then
I think it took a lot of foresight and
presence of mind and intelligence to be
like let's make sure that were the jokes
always on us right now
I had a thing and I posted a video and
it was really was a super well received
I was uh we're at the beach in San Diego
and there's just you know like a tick to
to leave the beach you go up all these
spiraling Starck staircases right and
and and halfway up as a shower so my
buddy's showering and I'm on the level
above him I'm looking down I'm like I
could just [ __ ] pull out my dick and
piss on do we need to know you know he's
like and he just wouldn't even know he
said I could piss all over there be
hilarious and then also I thought oh
whoa this is great about a prank where I
go around pissing on people
yeah yeah yeah right problem but just
whenever but that's something and that
figured it out I was like okay you know
legal to it for their strangers right
but but I was I was going so quickly
they have is this thing called the whiz
inator where it's like if you're if you
want to pass a drug test
you can go in there ticket it's a
[ __ ] fake like a prosthetics ghetto
I've heard about that looks exactly like
a dick it's connected to a bag you can
warm it up and you consider stuff there
if you're if your parole up have you
ever used that like for real right now
for real bird was going on but I went to
I went to like the bond shop like the
head shop and I bought myself it's
called a whiz inator and and so I'm like
a kid so I filled it with warm water and
start and then in the beginning of my
video I'm like I'm like this is not my
dick Jordan's right I've learned it
better but sure it wasn't my dick yeah
it looks it looks so it's so exactly
it's designed so that your probation
officer can look at your deck and make
sure that the pizzica mandatory that in
fact it's not exactly and so I'll
faltering the show by the way just for
the record right so when I went to uh to
the beach
it's like hidden cameras law Mike and
like dudes who were like sleeping child
look and I just know I just when I just
went up to the
and [ __ ] uh and just like with it
what's the whizz Nate and I squirted
warm water like on their foot right I'm
sure they would wake up and they would
freak out they see a dick and like you
know and I'd like did you ever get like
the videos on there and it's called the
golden shower creme no-one ever try to
[ __ ] you up from that no I couldn't wrap
the video until I did - like a muscle
dude okay yeah of course
and and descent my experience was that
everyone woke up and they were initially
shocked they're scared they back off and
then they took like a second look and
they were like oh that's evil okay and
it was like I got away with it my god
they were a good away the fact that they
knew you don't I keep going die thank
God they got me out they were like and
then at the end oh my god like I was and
thank I didn't just go and put out and
go on up to like small dudes I did it
like a real big like military muscle man
dude and I [ __ ] in the guy got up and
he's like everywhere and he's like take
off your glasses and I'm sure he's
telling me take off my glasses he can
punch me and to my credit I stood there
and took them off the yet here it is but
not the my whole point with it is that
as I as I do regularly a lot of the time
I'll run something by Knoxville you know
name is spike you know like I'll send it
to guys be like hey you know I can't get
it give me notes on this before I put it
out and knock so is super not down this
is the golden shower prank because it's
a little mean yeah hello main spirit
because you're pranking other people
right and and my argument with him about
my outside see I get it but the thing is
that like the the twist of it all it's
so it's it's so like water it I got it's
only of course it's on the water and
when people went like when there's a
whole like unexpected oh my god you're
steve-o a lot is great they're giving me
hugs everything it really made it light
you know I made it light and then at the
end like I went up so I did I really
rolled the dice with a huge guy he made
me take off my shirt to him thinking oh
my god I'm about to get me wet out there
when me take off my shirt and I turn
around then once he saw my bag tetras
like you [ __ ] I wanted to buy a kill
huge so it's a prank only steve-o can do
I guess I some it's some bad guy but
that way when I think of that line and
how would see YouTube and knock so said
I'm not back in it and I was like you
know I think it's white it's light
enough that I'm going to run with it and
and there's somehow on YouTube not
there's just not that sensibility in
place because there was no comment I
mean I'm not going to read comments I
came and speak for comment but the like
ratio did I get back a like so sure
right Mike's versus dislikes it the
golden shower prank was like at the top
pathway this is on your YouTube yeah
oh guys could hit up to go on shower
let's drop some likes on that ah do you
John something looks good
actually let's watch that you want to
watch it go for it dude is that
constitute a break
nope oh it doesn't do you want a break I
mean I don't I don't want to watch it
whenever to go I like watching stuff and
then we can not even watch it together
and comment on it okay how about that
but don't let me know if you need to go
back for some [ __ ] you Bri what are you
golden shower prank go they can see this
oh yeah I haven't done pranks in some
time but this is like a perfect like
fake YouTube prank like if some
prankster did this it would definitely
be fake well right but I never presented
it as as well it was real - oh you knew
they would put there was they'd set up
the guy Oh God haha yeah exactly
staged a reaction I really remembered it
with an actor pretend to be a milk how
did you fill in your first all that
stuff like all these pranksters
pranksters doing all the fake pranks and
blowing it up 30 million is that we love
they were on like I remember back in the
day they're all in like news channels
and [ __ ] yeah they were was a year of
the prank it was it like 13 or 14 it was
14 I think yeah when I launched my
channel in 2013 because god I die I was
sitting on my idea for my first prank
for so long for years I had the idea to
to pour into a condom like dishwasher
detergent that looks like [ __ ] oh god
this [ __ ]
and and like have a use rubber and then
I went walking around in public and
people would say oh no it's people can I
get a phone I'll be like of course man
and do check it out I love and I pull
out the condom and I determined that
people want to get a [ __ ] photo with
some of it somebody who they recognize
some TV show man like I'm handing like
hoes versa yeah how do you hold it
remaining you know and dude this is
rabbit lose Robert I love you it's like
Neville I love where your prank minds at
because you're like I'm famous now I can
step my pranks up to the next level and
is this I I mean I wish there like I did
it again I personally the the condom one
and my very few people were fazed at all
like oh yeah cool no no what do you do
though you confronted with the dirty I
almost like a lion that was that was the
first things as well it was not very fun
person by the way guys if you're not
acquainted with what steve-o's youtube
channel check it out there's honestly
amazing content there here's my biggest
beef with YouTube right and I'm just so
[ __ ] mad about this right is that is
that not just the algorithm not not
YouTube as an institution but but really
the mentality of the YouTube audience is
to reward frequency and punish yeah in
frequency and so it's like when I went
when I put and I approach it my
mentality is like okay I don't want to I
don't want to put anything out unless I
really think it's top notch you know I
was right I would not want to insult my
audience with with like quantity over
quality and so on so as since I started
my channel in 2013 I had posted in the
beginning it was closer to every two
weeks but and with no real regularity
and now it's like every like two months
you know months I've done drop is all
your fault good and it's not the fans
it's YouTube's algorithm first of all
favors frequency okay
but I think and also it is the audience
to be gotten
it's the audience as well as I said
because it's a different experience they
want something to watch like I wanted to
be there
Rapinoe of youtube I don't know if I
would blame I see this is what YouTube
so insidious because they [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] and you don't know if it's them or
not you end up blaming yourself or
you're like man what's going on it's
confusing but I'll tell you what pranks
are not popular in usual I meant the
pranks [ __ ] they don't dude I really
think indeed why to go and tell these
like ancient Jack Astor's when like
there's the current stuff on my mind
that I wanted to bring them there's one
thing I thought I had like a little
mental list of things to talk about yeah
and the one thing there's two things
that [ __ ] piss me off and I hate that
even bring it up and because the people
I really genuinely like who are culprits
of this [ __ ] crime better fair you
know people generally like guys are
doing this thing that irks me okay
[ __ ] like I love it
what is I gotta know like that way
artificial positivity Oh Natalie then I
laughs damn it
that is an epidemic on you right now
it's just like my workload comes come
high returns to normal more because I'm
not into that but just like this ayat by
the way is a bunch of the kids invention
small more there's a bunch he's where he
sells hats this is smile more people
walk in their sleep some people walk
around but just credit ease in doing
that that's been a deal for laundry I
thought it's just like Oh guys your
dreams can if you just dream and believe
and it's like I mean I get it I get it
and if anything like hey man like I'm a
strong believer that there's really no
such thing as luck luck is just when
prep the projects when preparation meets
opportunity
you know if you're prepared then when an
opportunity presented out there enough
amount of time right I've said that and
I believe I believe in I believe in in
and in front dreams like a dream is sort
of organized to my right you know in
like way more like news when you have in
[ __ ] a dream a dream is a goal with
no [ __ ] elbow grease you know a goal
is a dream with the [ __ ] actual right
action route your own taking place I'm
all about all that positive [ __ ] it's
just that when people yes if you can
so that people are thinking are man like
how am I going to get more like yeah how
am I gonna get one bikes how might you
know engage it
let me just [ __ ] put on some like oh
we're fake and the people he'll sell it
I feel like our miserable generally yeah
and it's just it's just pedaling too you
know what I don't agree I don't get that
fans who actually believe it right okay
and before I ask people guess let me say
at least if you're gonna put if you can
have this sort of this is uplifting
saying I mean I was deliberately trying
to be uplifting I said I had this
nihilist limited things coming down here
but there's an honest way to do it in a
really grads or have it have it be
pertinent to what have the message be
built into what so that it makes sense
it pertains to what's going on don't
have a [ __ ] picture of you stand in
there and then some caption that goes on
about [ __ ] positivity and like you
know how to and and one other thing and
there's two people I can think of who
are who are so dear to me but this is
going to break my heart I know what a
little isn't it let's go please stop
[ __ ] jumping on trampolines and
[ __ ] stupid I don't care why do you
put on the [ __ ] what are you Hannibal
you say together
yeah have you never seen more bees on a
trampoline or beam on trampolines you
ready it's fun another candidate no I
mean you even care why your brother I
see all I want to know it I'm already a
fitness swimming pool that's all i cart
did okay i wrote a movie script right
I'm really excited I'm alright so it's
thrilled about the description I had one
scene one scene that that was really a
big scene and it took place at a State
Fair and I was thinking ah man like if
I'm going to be at a State Fair really
need to do stunts on like a ferris wheel
or a roller coaster sound like big epic
like thing and I'm not taking advantage
of it I think it's going to be explained
seven and and it's just hard stars like
I gotta let go to the State Fair and
then I thought about my buddy for my
circus days who is he was a boss clown
in the Ringling circus and he was like
the the you know what about one of the
administrators of clown college and he
became the ringmaster of this great
circus that has no animals and he should
go see it at photos mostly in California
it's called circus Vargas and I was like
I'll cool man like I could switch this
hand from State Fair to circus I just
looked up at Google it's a circus Vargas
it happened to be in [ __ ] Burbank
that night so my scriptwriter and I was
like dude [ __ ] what come on we're going
to the circus so we went to just like
scope everything out and looked
everything and this is [ __ ] so killer
like you know I'm like okay so because
in the movie I'm running from running
from the law and and so it's like I get
to the you know I get to this circus
where the guys you know whatever I'm
hitchhiking woods he's got to go there I
come out the cops chased me into the big
ten and then [ __ ] motorcycles are
driving around the globe of death and
the cops are chasing me and so I'm like
[ __ ] and I go climb up into the rigging
of the [ __ ] of the actual big top you
know and I we went around I went
backstage I was like the behind
everything I figured it out that I can
actually is logistically make sense I
can climb up into the rigging and the
cops come about me and so I try to go
across a high wire and I even saw
theoretical planning for you oh yeah but
you know it all and it all like works
logistically two sheets are made I made
some fact-check and then figure out
another research so I try to go across
the high wire to get from away from the
cops by a fall and you know and I'd
crawl across then go up into the rigging
and further up into the rigging and
there's like a hatch to come out where
the tent pole is right you know how to
do the piece of it yeah so I can come
out of the to get away from the cops
crawl inside the tent where I climb up
out of the time on top of thing and I
jump up and slide off the whole fun
binge in [ __ ] yes line off the whole
thing and [ __ ] can eat [ __ ] on the
ground and then and then [ __ ] and now
I'm outside so I've got like a real bona
fide head start away from the cops and
then like the first trailer I'm like oh
I got hide the first trailer going to is
the clown's dressing room and we've
established me as a guy who is a history
the character I wrote who I play is also
a clown so what I get is on truth so
then so then I thought again I'm in the
clowns with him and I [ __ ] make
myself into a clown right come out on
face to face with the [ __ ] head
investigator cop who's trying to find me
that he holds up a picture of his have
you seen this guy and I'm like please to
shake my head like now and so whatever
the thing was a thing like that had my
vision for Thomas story and gratuitously
like promoting my authority let go more
class and I participated in there and
participating as I watched the show like
I and then [ __ ] I love I've seen circus
Vargas come every year like I think
three of the last four years or I don't
know I believe it every year was it
about the circus that you love I've
never been to the circus never occurred
to me that I wanted to be a clown
it was just I wanted to be a stuntman
and I was the way and I thought if I
could go to Clown College I would be a
trained service professional that would
help me so for those of you who don't
know and I find it's just one of the
many fascinating things that I've
learned about you is that you went to
Clown College I went to Ringling
Brothers and Barnum Bailey put me Oliver
yeah I didn't know everything I thought
it was harder to get into Clown College
than Harvard all right but no so now I'm
at circus Vargas and this is only a
couple months ago if that and had
trampoline act right at a [ __ ] train
way back and these world-class
[ __ ] these world-class [ __ ]
at just the level of acrobatic
[ __ ] ability and mind you like the
circus community just would there's no
way that they would want to be on
YouTube because then you can see it on
YouTube I would go buy a ticket and go
to the circus yeah so they're trying to
avoid and I'm just thinking in my mind
to compare these [ __ ] people with oh
this time we put we this time we put
corn flakes on the [ __ ] trampolines
invested oh yeah I'm like well I'm just
I'm like oh my god like like these
[ __ ] dis sure this trailer
disrespecting the art this why me
they're disrespecting and they get
amused but did put the biggest crap
outside these [ __ ] like quadruple
twisting [ __ ] triple pipe back flavor
[ __ ] going on and they're just every
balance is is is it's just incredible
it's impressive and then though and then
these these [ __ ] flopping themselves
onto a [ __ ] trampoline that happens
to have some [ __ ] light on it
I came Iran has over both what is please
then into the YouTube audience stop in
washing so I have this thing that so
watch it says trampoline covered in some
[ __ ] you just don't like it
watch it or trampoline but isn't anyone
you could be the biggest consumers
here's the thing about I have you though
on you you whenever you see something
like that you can't explain it so stupid
like who the [ __ ] is watching this the
answer is only and every time one thing
kids I mean it was it was it was dope
for a while but now at this point we
have seen we trampolines covered in
[ __ ] [ __ ] I actually haven't seen
actually honestly I haven't seen [ __ ]
sounds like it's um it's not well gee
there's still there's an old territory
to explore it sounds like I won't make
want to try a new idea for steve-o's you
could go just lock it up that one ends
the whole thing what [ __ ] is not brent
friendly so those guys are not going to
do that right I would start to get
another trampoline video with my
homeboys the juice box is so deep to the
trampoline to attune that guy to their
credit my homeboy jacked any of the jig
squad really single-handedly started the
trampoline verses phenomena well I'm not
mad at him for that I'm just mad as
everybody [ __ ] a totally trying to
wring out what's the Dumber I wanted reg
to the [ __ ] I the the last milk a yeah
I mean it's ringing out every last drop
out is on YouTube though every any time
like the fidgets spinner [ __ ] the one of
the most obscene ones was the heating up
[ __ ] yeah the knife the knife look I'm
pretty proud of what I did with Jack
Canada I was like hey
let's do something new with the
Champlain and we built it on to a
[ __ ] pickup truck I saw that every
guy can like like pretty high speed so I
can move in pickup truck with the
trampoline mounted onto it and bounced
off of edge I saw that you got in
trouble with the police for that right I
did
I'm such a maniac I'm such a [ __ ]
maniac I'm on probation right how just
for further it wasn't that it wasn't
that it was very gnarly in there it may
be 30 feet like a bipod between 25 jumps
from an overpass into the river with the
speed of the truck I didn't just fall
down you can see in the video and
exactly you're USBs odd dih it is doing
it landing on water made me bleed
there's only time my life that happened
but um and then the plea how did it
happen to please knock out on your ass
for that right what this isn't saying is
I'm on probation from something I didn't
do that one clearly where I climbed up a
crane
she had a protest SeaWorld and be an
attention [ __ ] I brought later will
killer whale up on this crane in like 80
firefighters 18 cops a helicopter and a
SWAT team all converged on the SWAT team
that's important but yeah we're gonna
shoot your ass
what they know you don't need that
because I 150 feet up in the air on top
of ugh I love they are on probation for
actually doing like activist [ __ ] right
right well it was like it wasn't pure
activism it was attention whoring meets
activist okay that's nice reading a
little touch of ration saving there
exactly yeah and I do believe in it so
it's not itself it's a sea world as [ __ ]
no hasn't failed to be authentic it was
it was authentic but so many kids if I
if I get arrested for some [ __ ]
then I'll violate my probation in my
life will be arguably difficult but I
was like when I jumped up and trampling
off the river bridge I thought man you
know if ever there was a cool thing to
violate my probation born this is it so
I sent the video to TMZ I was like hey
guys here's this video I'm liking it
nobody seeing it I'm not going to post
it for a couple more days so you guys
can have like a 48 hour exclusive for
TMZ if you want to run this video and
what makes it particularly like note
notable and newsworthy is that it
clearly constitutes a violation of my
probation sorry eyes
set it to TMZ with the footage and and
told them like that what makes it what
makes it what makes it newsworthy is
that it's totally against the law and
should violate my pride tried violate my
own information yeah like in Romania and
then as soon as I said that I was like
what am i doing
what do I know I'm not ya know yeah all
right I'm like what am i doing I'm not
this is bug crazy like well I'm out of
my mind and thankfully the the county in
Florida where this happened determined
that since nobody called it in and since
like they did and and I forget what the
name the county is but it's like south
of Tampa and on the the west coast of
Florida and I went to the Twitter
because I was copied in some things and
go there investigating right and so I
clicked their Twitter link and it
actually said on their header like their
bio whatever for Twitter isn't there the
this they are mindful like as a whatever
you know a police department they're
mindful to not waste money of the
taxpayers no no and they're like this
just isn't [ __ ] worth it
that's a minute ago great this wonderful
audit so they said they said nobody
[ __ ] called it in
it wasn't [ __ ] worth our time we just
didn't nobody got hurt
we don't care yeah and and so that the
thing was I was off the hook
that's actually awesome god bless them
right god bless saying I didn't
understand that I thought they came
after you but turns out they were very
they did they're been different things
where they did come after me but uh yeah
that was it that was a particularly
reckless case of me trying to violate my
probation I think that is pretty I don't
know about that combination I'm
suspended as far as to the you chose to
message TMZ and also I feel like
everyone's like running away on them um
based on their like such douchebags
right well no when when Ryan Dunne
passed away I mean I saw that story how
they run you up in the middle band right
and they're like right you know that
your friend died and you're like I that
I that was shitty that was it sounds
really shitty that was sure that was how
I found out
and then my buddy died was because six
o'clock in the morning my phone rang I
was totally asleep and I woke up and
they said hey it's pansy I were calling
for a comment can we get you to comment
i'm your buddies debt and then and i
just woke up to that like and I was like
huh like what he's talking about and I
was like no I can't comment you know and
then I woke up and then sure enough that
was the case that was you should believe
it at first like what was going through
your head then uh I mean I I didn't want
to believe it I didn't like I don't know
I just like it was so just like you know
ha and then churn out there was real and
that was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] thing
to do really you know it was a piece of
[ __ ] way to handle that situation but I
don't know do I have beef with tansy for
that or no I think that my relationship
with TMZ like I should say that's where
I get my news really I'm not yeah I
thought I got I wake up the morning
timsy I'm how do I go to Tim's that's
where I get my news like they are like
like I'm there
absolutely piece of [ __ ] yeah people
right there there they are a piece of
[ __ ] institution which does piece of
[ __ ] things but with that said their
journalistic integrity is sound they're
true they don't work they do not like
yeah that's what I've heard really have
journey broken some big stories actually
a lot of it they don't lied they're like
a tabloid they are a piece of [ __ ]
tabloids that has a virtually impeccable
record a record for journalistic
integrity insofar as reporting what is
true yeah yeah so to that effect I
believe everything I see on there is it
appropriate is it spiritually like the
high road no but but but but is like is
there something compelling about
learning of the misfortune of others
absolutely bonus why do you if I watch
you so why do you think I watching you I
curate that's all we do man right so you
know it is what it is man and I also I
should say as a consumer of media that I
believe in I just I'm entertained by
James Ian and it's factually correct and
as a manga of media attention it's a
tool man and if I've got something that
that I did I like to take a couple days
to edit my video and so why wouldn't I
give to give them a 48 hour head start
and it's it's not exact you
you can't like hold a grudge against
them there's none of these things where
it's like tons of pot and even even the
the Ryan Dunn debacle it's different
people making different choices you know
I held it personally against the one
person who made that phone call but I
let that go a long time ago and and I
just it was a bad judgment call now in
person but I didn't hold that didn't
hold that as a grunt I just I remember
seeing that clip of you talking about I
found it fascinating just that whole
situation was like so [ __ ] right yeah
so just shitty right just almost
hilariously shitty thing for shitty and
here we are
[ __ ] three days three days it was the
anniversary of Ryan's death well the day
we're talking about was six years and
three days ago Wow
yeah that's crazy hat time flies almost
seems like long and fought like short at
the same time right I heard about it
it's so [ __ ] crazy at times wise man
you know I'm a boy I've been clean and
sober for nine years now I'll clap for
that thanks Anna I don't know that it's
a clap or something you know I heard
someone make the distinction that
they're not proud of their sobriety
rather they're grateful for it and I
identify with that interesting well what
what do you mean by that like well
somebody like data from dear friend of
mine may be my favorite for the sober
guy who's an entertainment lawyer he's
been sober for over 30 years
and he said that he went out to dinner
with a woman and mentioned that even so
Bree said I don't know why I mentioned I
just did and she said oh why you got to
be so proud he's not not proud I'm
grateful so now I don't really come on
that's a big deal like to get pestering
by like I really got to be proud that's
a big deal can I give you some credit
there's no I'm not proud Rick said a few
times he said then I was sending finally
to look yeah how did how did he put it
recently he said he said look being
proud of an alcoholic for staying sober
is like being proud of a cowboy with
hemorrhoids for staying off a horse the
cowboy was ready for the cowboy who has
hemorrhoids is grateful that he's
managed to stay off the horse right
grateful and grateful implies in some
way that you don't take credit for it
though well yeah and you know why should
you do you feel like like you don't
think thing about alcoholism which is
like like long proven many [ __ ] years
ago is that the alcoholic of his own
like personal power cannot combat
alcoholism we cannot stay sober alone I
would try to do it on our own we get
loaded every time it's when we get
together with other alcoholics and we do
it together and as it like a fellowship
as a communities as people help how we
stay sober by helping other people get
sober was that the drug do it we don't
do it by ourselves and so why would we
take credit ourselves ah that makes
sense right the community effort we took
that we cannot do it but that's a
beautiful and that is so important it's
important that you not try to do it by
yourself okay that actually that's only
going to you yeah dude what's up dude I
feel bad I feel like bashing on the
trampoline maybe people like back to the
trip people might really you know if
they like trampoline oh we're gonna
triple it if there's come in if there's
demand for it then trample me
all the trampoline videos on YouTube and
I want you to smash that dyslexic guys
let's talk more [ __ ] what I'll see you
later
what else do I hate um I think that you
and I you guys like I think taste of
hate I said I do and can we get can we
give ourselves a pat on the back first
like an absolutely eviscerating the part
when you're five
did you hear that aftermath of all that
lost their child for they're lifted
about that how did you feel about that
yeah my I had very conflicted - I don't
think that what we first of all we had
you're saying you're saying that you
have feelings of guilt for that oh I'm
conflicted about like is that a good
thing or not I don't think me and you
hold any battles anyway it was so plain
first of all our approach to that was
like very much in the spirit of Jack us
like you were saying like we weren't
mean I think we approached it in a
really funny there was nothing
comparable about jackass and what we did
with Daddy of five I mean in the spirit
of nothing comparable about it because
jackass is something that uh that you
contrived there or what they did is not
comparable though of course that's
saying the video that you and I made
together it was a reaction video like I
said we create something from scratch
and it's got its own premise or whatever
it is it's it's own thing
like where as what what we did was way
more journalistic it's like okay now
let's take some chicken but everything's
separate that is a sign tone and and and
and what I mean is like to inherit it
wasn't it was next one expose we added
them we drew attention to something
which is like black and white [ __ ]
rock yes I would say that we passed
judgment on it but there is no genuine
sedately so clearly yeah I mean the
attention of the video for me going in
was to be funny I didn't want to be like
overbearing like the press like look I
don't want people to go and that was why
when you said something that at the
beginning of the podcast about where we
felt like it was going badly during yeah
yeah I expressed concern when we made
the video like how do you I don't know
if this kicks ass like I'm worried like
that we didn't make a good good video
and you said oh don't worry about it I
think that's where I came from is it
yeah it was so it was
serious subject that we were dealing
with yeah what is showing I'm dark you
had a so dark house I caught me in that
I felt like I wasn't funny it's like oh
yeah that's why we were talking about
childhood yes you mean of course you
weren't fun you made that comment to me
after we had busted the video right I
think it was on the phone and you're
like man I realize finally why I felt
like I couldn't be funny we're watching
actual child abuse comes and get things
get there I think I did a pretty good
job right and so there is a big backlash
for that and of course it then that's
great I guess how do you feel Child
Services came and took their kids away
let me just say premise I don't feel
responsible at all for what happened but
how do you feel about them losing their
kids and apparently I don't think that's
a permanent situation where they lost
their kids I don't they went and lived
with her mom who's apparently also a
total loser piece of [ __ ] alcoholic
lunatic would you I didn't what the
beginning so they took the kids away
from the dad who was making money on
YouTube they were making a good living
and now we're really making that money
yeah they were I mean they're making an
ominous a must ever for a family and
[ __ ] Arkansas whatever they're you
know yeah here's the kids went and moved
in with their [ __ ] mom bigger a bigger
picture question to ask you know do I
feel bad about that like like no of
course not because look at what they
were look what they did the bigger
question is like like how is it that for
some people like a [ __ ] up means the
absolute end of you're done and that's
it you're never coming back
and then there's Chris Brown Cruz
brothers first of all Chris Brown's a
piece of [ __ ] and [ __ ] that guy why I
completely agree like I said I agree
with you from our sensibilities are
aligned but my question is Chris Brown I
can't like like a he look what he did to
Rihanna's [ __ ] face he dresses like
he beat her nearly to death he'd be
heard [ __ ] man there's no way there's
no he can like hit someone in the face
that hard not to do some kind of
branding that I was reading I was
reading the police right and then and it
was not an isolated incident where like
are you can explain the rage I think
there's been thing after thing after
thing at the thing where it all points
to the same [ __ ] pattern of that just
the kind of guy he is yet yet he why
does it happen
popularity people like him nobody gives
a [ __ ] about daddy five
and he's gonna [ __ ] not only does
Chris Brown continue to have like
concerts in arenas extremely sick he's
more sense he sells out Arena and Miami
I think that the the gender ratio at a
Chris Brown concert isn't is largely
female yep when I first heard about a
beautiful I had no idea we were we're
doing the reaction video to DJ Khaled's
first video and Chris mom was in it and
I didn't know what for defeating it was
yeah very first one with Chris Brown
that was before he should ever really
maybe on a different one because I
remember you have not everyone doing out
about that I was are you serious are you
were the one who told me about [ __ ] me
I'm pretty sure that's what I was going
to say huh
yeah yeah he's a total [ __ ] and the same
year the same year daughters well anyway
my point was that I was shocked that
that happened and he still was making
like really popular more popular than
ever
and I never even heard about the the
whole thing I just right that's the same
year he should have Rihanna several
months later he was hosting and
performing at the Grammys right and
people were applauding him right right I
mean and then what's it like Mel Gibson
what were you gonna say you said I
shouldn't say this i seduce baby it's
nothing particularly things just it was
there to give up where I live that I
live good neighborhood I move oh you
live near Chris Brown Chris Brown I had
like this is in the summative you get
your news from TMZ you would know that
he famously was spray-painting graffiti
on his own house okay there's a big wall
of his own house he was spray-painting
in pretty talented artists right guys
these monster characters apparently like
I did terrified all the children
neighbors are complaining with their
kids live because he's scary monsters
around and it was just unsightly and kid
is the worst neighbor ever okay and I'm
very very close into the same
neighborhood at the point when I bought
my house just over three years ago um
Chris Brown was in jail and selling the
house so he was never there after I
moved and got it but I just have more of
a oh my god right in the [ __ ] this
particularly [ __ ] pisses me off and
it's not a known fact about Chris Brown
he spent 50
thousand dollars at this old house to
build a [ __ ] huge cage ostensibly to
breed pit bulls what a [ __ ] loser
brietta low like this thing ever like on
it has been a dog fight it had Michael
Vick written all over a dude okay you
doesn't know about dog fights so but to
breed Pippen and in just like many
things I'm seeing if you're all the time
because I go hiking around there so you
know about first of all this episode of
sample with the cockfighting yeah it's
like this whole it used to be illegal
it's a total sociopath thing where they
create fighting dogs to fight and kill
each other in the ring and you bet on
them so it's extremely illegal now but
it still happens underground it's like
what you have to be a real sicko to get
pleasure editor had that he probably
doesn't not we should say that then we
don't know you heard it here you know
you don't know absolute like reading
reading people's and fighting pit bulls
is something let's just say let's it
like we're drawing the heart if you
would you can't we can't arrive the good
we're drawing a conclusion right whether
is where there's no in our opinions that
seems a likely conclusion from I would I
would have suspicions I would have a
very efficient the imagining students
like crystalline Doug right I mean I
can't save her at all we're like there's
definite but apparently like I don't
know I can't see him was a doing that
someone said he said I can tell this
here just and expenses I heard fifty
thousand dollars to build this [ __ ]
ridiculous cage and as soon as you put
dogs in into it apparently they just
were crying so loud oh oh and so
perpetually non-stop applying the trying
that it was just a misfire and then put
them in there and and he couldn't keep
him in there cooking and so this cage
remains any of their been to how to
owners someone bought the house a dude
and then that owner assaulted two trees
and now owner who's a woman right and
the entire interior of the house has the
same graffiti like painted all these
characters all over the walls in the
house in the garage and I know for a
fact that the first owner who bought it
from him
kept that prison-like Kris Pilon into
the preserve I don't know it's a woman
who now lives in it have painted over to
imagine i right that's probably a
repaint I don't know no I would have to
imagine it as you kept it
I'm really curious one of thousands of
women criminals
Christian you're crazy this house is so
[ __ ] tall it is so [ __ ] tall that
like to live in it
I can't believe the Chris Brown put on
any weight while I was living there
because you got a little bit chunky at
one point didn't do you got in your GW
Brown you can't nothing good let me have
a living stairs here I'm going to show
you guys Chris Brown's our fees right no
I don't like I'm like yo see there's
outside the house and there's also
inside the house if I'm buying a
beautiful and no it's in a nice
neighborhood I'm not sure I want this a
my adoring my oh I read where that I
guess I was by the [ __ ] out what I
don't understand
I can either not it that's not it okay
it's his house you are said Chris proud
not that's not his house he died on
things well I mean here it's brown house
you okay
Chris Bosh's graffiti but wires mount
has Chris found houses old house right
yeah it is which was over to live the
middle middle of the Lamborghini right
there
here yeah oh that's hideous right well
let me I look at something when done
graffiti I don't get that one it's good
scare because the neighbors hate them
because what's a rich white neighborhood
probably it's not actually that's the
other than surprising is considering how
like you sell that arenas in the house
like you sold it pressing 1.5 million
that looks like when there's a little
bit too sensitive of the neighbors first
of all I wouldn't complain but you when
you get into like these weird like rich
upper class neighborhoods like it's just
like some urban [ __ ] is east of the 101
FES [ __ ] its east of the 101 where Rio
says way less than really yeah it's like
I'm surprised he didn't have a more
expensive house but the neighbors
[ __ ] hated him so much because at all
hours of the night [ __ ] parties which
is like the whole roads just blah
honor cars parked and it's just her
music and people were like people say
like please please can you turn it down
he'd be like [ __ ] you dude right why
there's just one great story you know J
Cole is now the famous rapper and she
doesn't see the interior the house so
she has this interior I'm like Olympic
but he has this story where he bought a
house and like a nice suburb of LA and
he was chilling mine in his own business
and the [ __ ] neighbors called the
police because they said that he's
selling drugs at his house and so the
police all raided his house without any
evidence of it aha so it's like just
because they're an anxious eye trapper
and like a nice manhood is immediately a
drug dealer and right I think that
suspicion is real and neighborhoods like
that
well like there's no suspicion going on
where you go oh it's very nice actually
it's styled it's not like all over the
[ __ ] place I would keep it probably I
mean he's done did and let's give him
props where he deserves and Chris Brown
can dance dude I've never liked if
there's ever a point like where it came
to my attention the crisper Chris
Brown's getting a lot of play this
podcast right if ever if ever I came to
visit there was a Chris Brown fine like
I said to be turned off I can't name a
single song I don't know
well he always does the same thing you I
have seen him dance and it's [ __ ] up
yeah you can dance yeah and he's a
little dangerous too
he's like oh [ __ ] dude and his old
banger and and she I would have drugs
like a mother but do you know what
people were saying after you beat the
[ __ ] of Rihanna they're like you can
like that [ __ ] should stop wanting I'd
let you beat me anytime like that's
great
but this I mean it's it right I think
the women were the one kept sending them
who else has been forgiven for just oh
yeah Roman Polanski was raping kids and
now people still work with them here's a
great one that [ __ ] drives me crazy
Brian singer producer of The X Files and
atonic our admin
sorry not exiled excellent he's a
producer and creator of a ton of [ __ ]
ton of [ __ ] there's a really good
documentary
has hung out with known serial pedophile
child rapists okay this guy has been
known to hang out at these Hollywood
parties with underage kids on drugs with
a [ __ ] kids oh yeah and he's still
working in Hollywood everybody knows
this guy I mean okay again what's one of
these alleged destroyed he has a
incredible resume on on this [ __ ] he's
work right again it's one of these
situations where it's like allegedly but
these sensibilities like when when you
call something out I'm right there with
it but the thing I think we're perfectly
aligned in our hatred for well it's
rational it's like right you know right
it's not a mystery the internet police
thanks Doug
yeah I think you need good internet a
better place this guy really pissed me
off this Bryan Singer guy let me tell
you like by there's been a ton of
accounts he's at the parties he's with
these kids and he's working with the
biggest stars in the world are still
working with him it's the same thing
with Polanski what was the name of the
documentary we saw I remember we all got
yeah under that list so the thing that's
fascinating about Woody Allen if you
guys don't know story he was married to
a woman and they had together
she had a thirteen-year-old or he didn't
adopt him she hadn't adopted Asian
Chinese Mia Farrow it was hit was
Shirley affero adopted an Asian child it
was hand after he left he left me affair
and married his own his underage
stepdaughter but here so that should she
was adopted so it's not I didn't know
that but here's where that story guy
thinks here's doctor I don't know that
should alone like though that
information is disgusting and weird as
hell but this is when it gets
interesting for me they stayed together
right I think they're still together so
in a way I'm like okay there's something
there was actually something there right
truly like a people you know I like I
mean really they stayed if they stayed
good for 50 years
right I mean not look at Beauty and the
Beast the Beast is [ __ ] tough
character root for yeah I went to see
that movie and I was like wait a second
why should I [ __ ] this guy right it's a
Chris Brown situation guy starts out as
a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] no redeeming
qualities come on he's a little mountain
and AFTRA turns into a beast he's just
still up spotting dick
nothing or dangerous
this is kind of a deep analogy what's
going on here this is the Chris Brown
[ __ ] girls my monster that is terrifying
but rich but rich and then even even
when he kind of got a castle that's all
he has gone even when he comes around at
the end and starts being kind of cool
it's very big grudge he's very cool very
he's bi he's got a problem
he's a dead like I don't shoot yeah he's
the kind of guy who'd be like I love you
baby and then maybe you [ __ ] serve
dinner a little cold and you catch one
on the fit chin right yeah and then he's
like my dinner serve local days so the
other way that documentary is called an
open sick and open to an open secret
family it's the dude watching a movie
about these producers and managers in
Hollywood who are [ __ ] kids talking
about this guy Bryan Singer who are
documentaries man this one is disturbing
and fast for the longest time and I had
a boycott against fiction citing that I
thought there's so much about the world
that I've heard oh yeah right I mean
[ __ ] I want to be people are so ignorant
you know I'll take her III yeah I'm
ignorant I want to learn about [ __ ] that
actually happen I don't have time to
learn about [ __ ] that didn't by the way
that's yeah that's really I think a
smart yeah and it's really just as
entertaining so you might as well but
that's why I think but then I then I
could [ __ ] had a Kindle I was reading
I actually broke down as an exercise I
shall read a nonfiction book and I got
roped into and then I was like flagging
it and then and then I got an iPad
Nesser watching Breaking Bad it's been
all addiction what I mean what's your
favorite TV show I would trust your
judgment on a TV show so okay across
across all genres and let me say there
when I when I tell you about your sense
really I mean you know that's it will
mean you look definitely guys are
clearly a lot of like one press we come
together and decide these things isn't
something you know right this is a very
serious about the absolutes like a
quality TV show I'm going to say number
one whoo I have an answer for this but
I'm curious what you going with the neck
the neck the neck this is across all
genres I don't know what the neck my god
like the Knicks of kids I have short
furred Knickerbocker Hospital
this is a [ __ ] period piece drama set
it's a drunken turn-of-the-century our
1900 partially based on on true events
as they as in in the year 1900 there
they were just experimenting with what
are now commonplace medical procedures
but to trial and error like the modern
medicine is going to be this and sort of
become shaping there's like it's [ __ ]
fascinating it's [ __ ] it's so good is
it an issue I can't believe it wasn't
more like an insanely popular Nick to to
more such it yeah there's two seasons
[ __ ] incredible
so my I think our favorite like dramatic
show is probably the wire I couldn't do
it man is my dark sauce try again so
I'll try again everybody was show no I
made like five I restarted that show
many times yeah I was so pissed because
I'm like how can the lead [ __ ]
accurate struggle with English so much
if he's from Baltimore why the guys I
can barely be able to talk I didn't have
the predominate [ __ ] guy he's not
Americans like what did imposter the
first time we tried watching it I didn't
understand anything and I was like all
done I'm not watching it by the way we
started over and we watched it with
English subtitles
yeah that's actually it really helps it
is dialogue so yeah it is really like
reading a book you know stringer Bell
you remember that character he's like
this gnarly Brooklyn [ __ ] Hampton
black guy we are not on the same page
okay well trust this news placing us
other than let me try again okay I trust
is not in this place well favorite show
of all time is Seinfeld yeah okay I'll
back that they fridge drama of all time
it's a underwhelming you know it's for
me the Seinfeld was like the beautiful
television you know like you can't argue
what I really enjoyed even though it's
slowed down in the middle was the young
Pope I was enjoying that
ELA made me turn it off oh yeah why she
wasn't into it she was Aikido down in
the middle but probably because it just
come all the it all just came together
for the most fantastic end I didn't yeah
I may
in like three EPs and i was starting to
get into eels like turn this [ __ ] off
see that she hit me Fastenal thank you
imagine they put this guy in place
because I think they can control him and
then all of a sudden it's gonna tick
yeah I was really into it the frame was
really interesting I can really and I
read and I waited until I finished the
the holes is the whole ceiling I wait
until it's over
- because I didn't want to ruin anything
with spoilers but our whole time I was
watching I was thinking oh my god be at
the end they filmed this in Vatican City
like so much of it there on location
making this which gotta be considered
[ __ ] ultimate blasphemous yet the
most this had to be the most [ __ ]
contrast and I was dying to research the
backlash of what is there did you look
up and find out and then what I what I
did come to really read I waited total
when I googled controversy young probe
HBO and apparently on the network that
aired it in Italy it was just so [ __ ]
insanely popular and you tell me and it
was and and they said that the Pope
himself was silent about it you know I
didn't speak up one way or another and
the guess whatever like maybe speculated
that the Pope was utterly pleased with
it the Pope is not-- we have a dope Pope
buzz there there's a style of evita dope
oh I'm do Joseph come around those are
the two shows I'm a young punk and the
Nick like visually the [ __ ] do with the
budget sector oh god yeah but what what
great dramatic shows do we love you know
what you'd why is the most incredible
shock that guy's been through like Oh
big transformations all throughout his
career he's one of those really
interesting actors unbelievable yo I got
to do this read really yes let me just
get this out here you want it should we
take and happy with that we should get
into the spooks
oh yeah we'll get into that okay here we
go guys I almost peed out okay here we
go here we go
you better be hot [ __ ] it should
be guys today I bring to you a gracious
and wonderful sponsor who has supported
our show and makes all this possible
steve-o's come out here is a great guys
blessed us with his presence here on
this podcast today and we thank our
sponsors for that today steve-o's back
we want to know the black tux this is a
really interesting service guys ok
you ever go you get into a wedding
you're going to event you go to a Bar
Mitzvah
ok it's a nightmare we lit what's up how
we doing
okay thanks sec we're getting a little
camera Justin this is really important
you go to a wedding you go to Bar
Mitzvah you go you have to go in and try
on a suit it's a nightmare you go you
fit it you go you come back it's and
it's usually very expensive so what this
company does the black tux what's
through URL black tux calm slash h3 make
it happen EULA so we still have minded
oh this is a really cool service where
you basically go on their website you
choose a tux you like you choose the
size they send it to you well before
your event and then you get to try it on
if it doesn't fit if you don't like the
style you send it back and they give you
a new style for free okay six and we
have it here yeah I've got it
let me I've got the whole thing here let
me show you guys so and it's it starts
at $95 and that is honestly super
affordable if you guys have ever rented
or bought suits that shake it's pricey
is out up to 1,200 bucks that's what
they wrote I can't confirm or deny that
they haven't been that experienced in my
they haven't been that expensive my
agent we all wear sandals even tech idea
but regardless 95 bucks is a pretty
slammin deal for for a tuxedo so this
jacket is actually feels really quality
how do I look all right the black tux
calm slash h3 check me out okay they
send you the jacket
the shirt the pants the shoes my god I'm
ready environments for today I want to
get bar Mitzvahed again low side even it
sucks I mean come on 95 bucks right you
get it you choose your style
you work with their customer service
within this one I don't know something
let me see that
oh is it an empty box this is important
to this boss let me see the bowtie you
want with the bowtie army there's so
much stuff in here anyway
it's a grit it's honestly a great thing
here it's a really useful convenient
service if you go to the black tux comm
/ h3 you get $20 off your purchase today
so if you have that special day come up
Bar Mitzvah I don't know why I keep
going back to Bar Mitzvah that makes
sense to me I'm a my imagination
everybody's everyone's headed to a Bar
Mitzvah okay looks like their site has
not crashed it so top of the morning to
you
so anyway where's the bow tied how's the
food I just at it oh there oh it's under
my okay and guys best of all the most
compelling thing of this offer the thing
that makes this all pop
the bowtie cops pretty hot kid anyway
we're ready for Bar Mitzvah
oh my honey my is it my bar mitzvah or
my entertainer I don't know anyway you
get that it tightens that's okay so guys
thank you to the sponsor a-plus with
free home try on you can see the fit yes
I said that
anyway it's a really cool service
there's a ton of different styles it's
sleek it's modern you guys know so
thanks for sponsoring us guys if you
have an event coming up made a lot if
you go try out their service you might
love it you're probably right and you'll
support us as well got got them okay cuz
I showed you that cool
everyone was saying that you look about
I like jacked go to the black tux calm
slash h3 and you look jacked like me
cool alright thanks guys for hanging out
do you want to do solo time I'm going to
take a break through the bathroom get
some coffee
how do you want some salt I'm so here
we're bringing you back some soil time
with your boy is I've and are you guys
beyond the solo [ __ ] oh god are you can
I think that's all they want
I love that [ __ ] you guys can out we get
a whale in the chat just so we can
visually see the solo appreciation here
it comes
solo there it goes oh they want ghost
stories we'll get into the ghost drawers
when we get back we got ways we got
yeses they don't care about a trooper
yeah they don't care about I mean we
have a higher number yeah it's a good
usual it's a good turnout how are you
doing right now
great are we are we over 15 K we've held
15k pretty pretty strong which is really
good yeah yeah the real cuz eating into
the territory of the longer podcast how
long have we been going actually it's
two to three hours okay I have no yes
how are they going to tell you two and a
half owns two and a half this is
definitely caso analytics tells you the
your retention rate so on YouTube we
have that info but the real test is on
YouTube which I think this is the
average viewing time
we'll repealed you're so technical yeah
what's going on here we are getting my
[ __ ] well you know I'm just curious
it's not about marketing your [ __ ] about
me wanting to believe that I'm holding a
stronger retention rate than the average
podcast that I am at you ollie you know
I'm going to crush the number I'm gonna
crunch the numbers and if it's bad I'll
lie to you it's gonna be great come on
you know this is I'm sure many people
have pointed out that this is exactly
like Howard Stern I totally ripped it
off yeah I will when we when we had our
set designer here I said well Howard was
like my inspiration for the show not
really podcasts my dream was to have
more acts and more stuff going on which
I think we can build up to but I says
ripoff Howard's set as much as possible
because I think I got the best set of
the letter the font is the same I'm a
huge [ __ ] Howard yeah yeah my dad is
like upset you listen to it on the App
the Sirius app know who you're blowing
it where else can you listen good though
thing is they see if you listen to it
streaming then whenever you stop the car
ready listen when you're driving mostly
right so when you stop the car
then it continues to play so right guy
the car you miss it oh yeah mr. Chuck
and then when you get back in the car
odds are you're going to rehear a trunk
so there's going to be certain parts
that you don't hear at all
and other parts that you hear twice
rehear now when you listen to the app
and we put it in run-ins with your
Bluetooth that's very cool
then when you stop the car you know you
stop the car it pauses where you are so
then when you get back in the car it
picks up immediately where you left off
say you want to move in you miss nothing
whatsoever and you never hear anything
twice and furthermore then after
Wednesday like you you're still stocked
up so you don't run out of Howard don't
run out of Howard okay I can't believe
you were on you I mean you I was on
Howard like and in my life like I think
16 times Wow yeah so Howard is like a
you see a different deal I used to be on
every way everyday he wouldn't have
these vacations all the time and it was
frankly if you
how old is he these days his eyes he
looks good
Oh seriously oh he's got that old 63 a
young man so but he's a legend on life
is order I can tell you like my personal
belief is that God I just can't I can't
go on you know like I only does three
days a week you know if I reach out to
Gary which I do very sparingly and
really try to not waste anybody's time
over there and say oh I got something to
promote or can I get on nice to know the
best I'm going to do is get on the
wrap-up show which I always do what I'm
hugely grateful to do I'd love to be a
part of them such a fan I have my Siri
not all these is Howard now he does a
lot less shows the only three days a
week but since he went on America's Got
Talent
this is only a theory but but people
it's big huge a list celebrity needs to
be terrified to go on how Wright has
cancer interviewer because you have to
ask questions about money and answers to
sexual should be hard it was too scary
so sorry a lot of people were afraid to
go on there and that's why I was so I've
gone there talk about whatever pray
right now I'd like but then I think that
him going on I like how the therapy that
he does in all this here and he's become
a more I don't know like less scary to
celebrity I think going on a GT had
something to do that America's Got
Talent
there's a judge often often didn't stop
him up at more mainstream it made him
more uh less scary you know it may have
been more family so you think he's got
like more he's acting like a tireless
like now it's just straight up a list
talk up a list Bonanza yeah and and it's
great I think it's a combination of less
shows and more interest it is like
there's less tated less sure it's harder
to get on and there's more competition
because now everybody wants to go on
there did Howard is [ __ ] crazy what
he's achieved and how like that has a
entertainment God it's crazy yeah that's
a real age I'm a huge fan and props to
you for paying homage yeah yeah much
definitely idly admit an up that we just
completely ripped off his studio
I'm like that I'm not going to try to
reinvent my studio design I'm just gonna
[ __ ] ripoff Howard Reilly good
science what they were doing well it's
pretty much just a fun I'm a humble man
in the game I'm just getting ready to
listen to Bill burr bill birnes
podcasters now and I'm talking about
Bill burr as a guest on Howard week or
two ago okay that's a great combo so so
yeah I'm Way behind what was it I don't
listen regularly my dad was a huge fan
of Howard so I've listened through it
through him but I don't write okay you
know I'm pretty religious about crazy
because I used to be on all the time I
never listen and then I became a little
super fan and I they won't actually like
Anna come on
you want to do some solo things you got
the champion okay give me a topic to
delve into talk about talk I hate this
because I miss the best part but I'm
going to use it anyway talk about that I
want to hell okay death
yeah talk about what do you wear your
this I want to know how craziest things
you've ever done on or off camera that
I'm buying weed in Jakarta like they
kill you
then I got my possession of marijuana is
possible of all the [ __ ] you've done it
the crazy well it's punishable by death
I can tell you the closest I've come to
death which is totally anti-climatic man
scuba diving they told me the Sharks are
at the bottom
I'm sorry hall and asked for the bottom
everybody's good with us
Wow Dan scuba diving's fun and scary man
I'll be back all right say yes all the
time
I'll take some suggestion see my best
drug story oh my god okay I'll tell you
oh my god this is [ __ ] up get ready
for a [ __ ] up story I used to do this
in my live shows but I determined that
it just wasn't [ __ ] funny I'm gonna
shut this door now
I
was so helplessly addicted to cocaine
it was insane like if I ran out I would
call this drug dealer and I was waiting
for a call from him I'd be like just
using my cell phone as a pillow so that
when it vibrated like it would wake
member be like oh yeah any drugs now if
I went to if I caught up the drug dealer
and if he didn't answer I would just
[ __ ] show up at his place
I would just go there look hot when I
got to his place I would I would try the
door sometimes it was open and I would
just walk in and sometimes it wasn't
open and that was upsetting this guy
okay this drug dealer wasn't just drug
dealer he's also like a hardcore addict
when I can I'm talking about cocaine
this guy would inject cocaine he would
shoot up and for some reason because I
never injected anything some reason that
I just don't understand about people who
shoot up cocaine is that with their
syringe they squirt their own blood all
over the place I mean this guy's
apartment it was off like this on the
walls even the [ __ ] ceiling the
furniture this [ __ ] had just
kissed with his syringes squirt all over
the place blood so I and sometimes when
I showed up and I would walk in I'd find
the guy like sitting there with like I
was literally needles [ __ ] hang on
silk it was hanging out of his neck one
time in here sitting there and I walked
in he was like whoa oh hey what's up
Dana pull needle out of his neck like oh
hey what's up bro you know like I [ __ ]
it was gnarly
and yeah I did whatever I wouldn't judge
him it's like oh yeah hey man I'll be
gonna give me some coke I would buy like
a bunch you know like Todd so I can
always buy like quite a lot and so this
one [ __ ] time I showed up his door
was not I was it was locked and I was
open I walked in it wasn't in the living
rooms in his back bedroom it was like a
guest house kind of deal and it wasn't
like an apartment but it was is like the
guest house he went like
the back of someone's driveway and then
his musing in the back and I walked in
so he's in his bedroom in the back and
like the dudes like he wasn't dead
obviously like but he was not responsive
you know he was so hidden I guess been
awake for so many days there's no
[ __ ] waking this guy up and he's like
I'm like trying to wake him up yeah I
mean I need [ __ ] drugs you know like
he there's no getting this guy up so
[ __ ] man like I just finally he's like
okay [ __ ] you know he's just sleeping so
I was not going to get him up so I went
myself into his living room to the table
where he would weigh out all his drugs
and there was from him weighing so this
guy's sold so much [ __ ] drugs that on
the table itself there was just like a
[ __ ] residue of coke is built up and
I'm looking at it like I knew that if I
took a card that I that I could just I
could scrape up like the gnarliest pile
of cocaine I just knew it I'm just like
I'm just going to god I want drugs and
I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna go [ __ ] help
myself I'm gonna scribble
so now I go and I sit down at the table
and I'm looking at there's cocaine
cocaine all over it but like I said the
[ __ ] squirted his own blood
everywhere so it's like cooking with
blood like splatters a thin like you
know and I'm like [ __ ] this is a
terrible idea like there's this is
[ __ ] bad and I'm like and I just
start scraping up [ __ ] cocaine and
like I can exist ibly like in the pile
and scraping like it I can see specks of
blood and this is the this is how
[ __ ] bad I was addicted sad there and
[ __ ] snorted the [ __ ] blood
dude what the [ __ ]
won't be on yeah I hate asking for my
craziest drug story that was on my I
wanted to ask you that well I got the I
watch the video drives dropped it I
watered it and Stevo literally said and
I snorted his blood I snorted the
[ __ ] blood did oh my god oh my
god
see I'm told I wrote about that story in
my book you know I think
it's like I should say they go on
podcast all the time I never [ __ ]
really promote [ __ ] like you're you're
right that I might have a [ __ ] crazy
life and and I have not only a book the
New York Times bestseller
and on top of this this is unheard of
for a best-seller the average customer
rating on Amazon for my book is a full
five out of five stars or you know
partial stars well if it's like a bona
fide flaw on five star numerical SL it's
called a professional idiot fortunately
it available in Amazon no whatnot but
[ __ ] Amazon because good Amazon on my
website I oughta graduate coffee
uh rather every single copy and like
inelegant pledge stars yeah and I am a
lot of people they charge a lot for the
merch on online like I got signatures
TiVo sunglasses for 18 bucks
that's actually pretty amazing but it's
not I got I got two shirts 20 bucks and
uh I got I have autographed books
like 25 bucks so I can fully autograph
so what is your autograph it's steve-o
calm so if you guys want some steve-o
swag
yeah I heard up man get over there and
fire that [ __ ] up way and uh yeah so now
like I talked about there's one element
to this drug dealers story that I've
never shared because it's [ __ ] up it's
five let's hear it now I'm intrigued me
though and the guys the guy remains
anonymous I've never like I'd not been
anybody would know him anyways like with
drug dealers and a long time ago but we
both got sober right like I got sober
first and then he starts showing up like
in places where sober people go at one
point the guy Essam at a place where
sober people go I can't believe I'm
about to [ __ ] say this it's like a
guy uh he says him in Kentucky and like
closing sideways but in private
conversation and he's like hey Dee I
know that at one point you snorted my
blood I really missed the beginning
person but I'll go with you
i'ma fall yeah he's like like this was
years and years after the fact so who
knows when but he was like like it so I
can I tell you it's like when we came up
hiv-positive it he wasn't [ __ ] with
you nah dude what the [ __ ] how did you
feel at that why I didn't give a [ __ ]
because I had I had at that point I
already been clean and sober for years
and like routinely [ __ ] tested you
know you were clean
I've been tested for HIV so many times
over and over and and that's the thing
about it is that God what this habit
wait hold on that's an important detail
you didn't just snort blood you have to
include a choice abroad one by the time
the reason when the blood was there
because the guy's an interviewer and
there's something about it [ __ ] you
snort is blood I need to know that I'm
not judging
you're gonna have to watch your little
white now black and why did it go oh my
god you guys get the best I'm gonna
leave really the best most interesting
[ __ ] goes down when I'm not in the room
right oh my god that's what we're
talking about HIV and AIDS rates with
the infected blood when it comes into
contact with with open air it really
does not live very long at all
that's why it's difficult to get aids
from a tattoo needle because a tattoo
needle is a solid needle right the
tattoo needles are solid knee or
anything on it is on the outside of it
and we're exposed to the air however
it's very [ __ ] an effective way to
get it from by using drug needles
because those needles are hollow and
it's like a little strong you poking in
and then
so within air cannot get all the way
through attacks was the opener got it in
the middle of that hypodermic syringe
needle which is essentially a straw the
blood that lives inside the needle
Michael there's an edge of it aids so if
you shared needle that's the way oh my
god is there anal sex is clearly how the
guy got it because because within within
that [ __ ] in the middle of that hollow
syringe needle when the bloods in there
[ __ ] it can live it can live for days
days I don't maybe even weeks and so if
you take someone on so take someone
else's [ __ ]
take someone else's [ __ ] drug needle
and you do that [ __ ] edge is alive
and well behind a syringe let it sit for
a week or more use it cracking run run
bleach through it you know that's how ya
know really yeah this like the pig
blazing up like an you know good that's
a good deal dude hidden in these new
storage what a [ __ ] creepy
[ __ ] relic on the gas pump you
can see if somebody showed me like what
the [ __ ] is this
it's on the gas pump and they're like
taping their used [ __ ] eight AIDS HIV
drug needle to the [ __ ] thing so that
when someone goes to grab the pump
hooah why would I do it there are people
out there - I don't [ __ ] could anyone do
that they're doing so when you [ __ ]
grab the gas pump then you get [ __ ]
that is H Oh [ __ ] jump jong-kook
google it they're googling try to
imagine a world where how you get aids
aids [ __ ] gas pump and then it's like
Eddie Murphy has this great bit we're
like this is like when people I was up
it was the same in stand-up but this was
like back when people hated it was like
cool to hate gay people and nobody know
House aides works and he's like your
wife go home with one of her gay friends
give him a kiss and then she come home
give you tips and you have AIDS and then
you have to tell people you have AIDS
and like of you [ __ ] dudes I don't know
that was a really butchering by the way
by the way he also has a bit and that
don't worries like I hate when white
dudes go and free to try to retell my
jokes
oh yeah I think about that got all
covered is that one right [ __ ] slam
dunk all right let's move on there's one
part of this show that inexplicably
inexplicably always comes up menial are
very skeptical people right somehow this
is a fascinating thing and everyone's
into it everyone loves it
we always ask our guests about ghost
stories well speaking of which the whole
dr. Lance whatever yeah yeah very long
as you said and then I trust you fully
like not implicitly explicitly write is
inaccurate I trust you expensable yeah I
trust you explicitly thoroughly yeah
like a hundred percent thanks and your
journalism on this guy's [ __ ] look at
that a bit
and yeah Bank with his jacket with the
jackoff cream I mean it could have been
there for like just like a cup no way I
mean if it's really fake its fake
we're cool of course but they're judging
you know how did the green screen yeah
and the jackoff
he was gotten happen it's not like it's
not like the guy was like oh it'd be so
[ __ ] funny if I made like I put a
jackoff cream there you know waking she
would notice that it was cutting up no
he was literally thinking that is the
event rate back to his bed and our job
yeah god what am I just trying jacking
off her with cream Canada don't go and
try every right so at whether thinking
about that now this guy wasn't what I
wanted to know he got him so bad I'm the
pulled out of bed it's [ __ ] real by
the way he's talking to ghosts and
spooks like like did you get any
backlash from Jersey I do you hurt my
feelings to take the video down and if
not hey has anybody that has been like
that stuff used to happen a long time
ago I think people stop they understand
now that there's no but we are being
sued right but before people understand
that our videos are not going to back
and I wanted to see I didn't want to
bring up the lawsuit or like or some
questions I'm really pretty interested
in because I got it I you know if I
can't talk about it I won't say but you
can have anything well I just think
they'd like me and I guess I come from a
different realm you know like I was
talking about you know like MTV like
sort of TV shows we made like movies and
it was a tough pill to swallow for me to
even learn how to add it to make youtube
videos to upload to YouTube I was
justified that's a good undertaking if
you edit all those by yourself yeah I
totally do and I love it I took them I
taking my life into my own hands and
before that before 2013 I was I did not
know how to edit a piece of video but I
would need someone to help and like
they're like I was I couldn't do
anything by myself and then and then you
know slack is such a gnarly it's such a
gnarly time and Noxon was making the
second
the bad grandpa and I was like [ __ ] he
like they're making jackass movie
without the Jackass guys you know not
now whether what is the bad grandpa oh I
know I ran it okay I'm like now now are
the Jackson for cousin
yeah we're now now I'm the Jackson for
right I we did like National Timberlake
done which by the way is not at all like
what happened you know and power to me
[ __ ] did that you know I like there's
like nachos - captain knowledge I'll be
in this day this is just my perception
my [ __ ] dark [ __ ] shitty [ __ ] is
it nihilistic the word nihilistic means
you don't care about anything okay right
Linda that's not pessimistic probably
message is my doomsday via can darn yeah
like I wish I was a novice like right
Olivia nihilist clack I killed or not
care about killing to be a nihilist
thanks for helping my my already
impressive vocabulary but let go yeah
serves I had this moment and when I was
up going on I was just like I'm over I'm
done with my mom Jackson floor I got and
then and then I just swallowed this
[ __ ] pill and I'm like I'm going to
become a youtuber man you know but it's
work but you were telling me it was like
a second the second life really revived
I mean so so many someone's everything
good has come about as a result maybe no
so like I [ __ ] you know does social
media like and everybody from not
following me on social media for god
sakes get on there please like nothing I
got like every way I won't waste your
time if anything I'd post considerably
less for them to be careful I that's my
philosophy as well to be careful so if
you see me I'm not going to clog up your
feet follow this man yeah it's paramount
but I wanted to tell you during this
moment when we were dissecting Lance's
video right he got pull out of the bed
right and I had this moment when I was
like way too self-aware and I was I was
like gala this is [ __ ] dumb like this
is obviously so safe why am i again and
it's so exactly I am I like bunking this
like this feels so stupid like well not
anybody ended up [ __ ] because we can
Jerry
used to see these Isis but I'm like okay
you're even after our next our video his
next video was still this is real still
right car like she's out in Israel what
is not wrong and wiggle it is
specifically referencing that one thing
yeah another Joey salads phenom well at
least he's not blaming black people it's
a victimless crime
yes are and girls under the bus what
alternatives are getting spookstreet
pregnant the reason I was talking about
when are you [ __ ] enquiries that's
the question yeah any ghost stories yes
and holy [ __ ] do I ever
let's hear it that's what let's go
alright yeah that's gonna happen thanks
but this got me other thing I didn't
want to get go anyway oh [ __ ] now I'm
intrigued dude was imagine like the most
like tangent is God like I have the most
[ __ ] up ghost story ever we gotta go
there do it I can't we gotta go there
yeah when I was doing drugs okay like I
did drugs to the point where I was
hearing voices okay like it's called the
technical term for in this would be
psychosis where is this a little mental
and and and what's what's so peculiar
about the phenomena of psychosis which
is characterized by audit auditory
hallucinations when you're hearing
voices visual hallucinations I was
watching people walk around my apartment
people who were never there I was one
hour walk through walls
same damn day they [ __ ] this stage
like an intervention on me at one point
I had like an apartment for people who
were there said to having a formal
intervention but they were never looking
they're aware that they wanted I watched
him I watched a [ __ ] you think
it was really you when you was around I
knew it was real into this [ __ ] day
was real in the shell [ __ ] damage but
in retrospect you liked that was
obviously a resonation totally [ __ ]
spiritual entities then the way right
now it's always why I think it was a
hallucination you think there were real
spiritual entities and then the [ __ ]
line is completely buried under minds
completely [ __ ] dirt and I think the
reason why I'm seeing them as
hallucinations is because they're yeah
do you think that the drugs like open
your mind I think is the deficit drugs
that's why I'd like was it with
psychosis I got like meth whether it
like I've methyl do it
so cocaine particularly on the third
straight day of a cocaine bender with no
sleep like wild
inhaling like nitrous oxide to the
exclusion of air as much as possible
right when when she would really pop off
and just you know she would pop off did
you invite it at one point okay the
first time I had like a spiritual like
intervention where it was like okay I
was sitting in and I was I was inhaling
nitrous oxide I was doing cocaine and I
had been doing so for two to three days
I was I was I was in a chair that was
fun just like this one and I was um I'm
seeing in front of a big pile of cocaine
and I'm sitting there I'm thinking
myself as I as I go to snort another
ridiculous helping of cocaine I thought
to myself wow I'm killing myself you
know like like there's there is no
longevity and we're like what I'm doing
I'm dying I'm dying here like this is me
killing myself and I'm dying and I
thought very specifically calm never
forget this it's not I don't care if I
die and I just leaned over to go [ __ ]
right now as I thought I don't care if I
die like as like as a reaction to those
specific words I thought to that thought
like physically in the spinning chair
then as I went to it [ __ ] spots I was
like a [ __ ] it was like there was a
big strong dude who [ __ ] spun the
[ __ ] terms like it was like with the
power of visit there was like a [ __ ]
mechanical bull it was just like a
[ __ ] saw and like and and it was not
granted this is a this is a tactile
hallucination meaning I like every feel
it
I know fully well that if there was a
surveillance camera in my apartment at
that time it would not reveal this
experience that I had right like I'm
clear on that but it [ __ ] can happen
what do you I wouldn't reveal like you
never spun at all you think which didn't
is that my experiences that I did but if
you're someone else in there
camera still it I got right it was it
didn't look like I know well I know well
enough to know that like this is an
experience that I had that was outside
of the dimension rover that were in
right and like it was so clear when this
happened that like I thought I don't
care if I die then whoa you know it was
like think again [ __ ] like think
again like this was completely in
response that I don't care if I died it
was like think again like you like the
message was clear that there's some
entity the distinctly cares that I not
die well we like Rick again I was like
[ __ ] I like something powerful is
[ __ ] just spawn this thing to genetic
the line we of course of course but
something powerful is [ __ ] wants me live
wants me to see the importance of don't
not care like like I should care
something wants me to care about living
like he's got to live for something yeah
I had and that thing might have been
later that night we know there was
another night when I had the formal but
benefit did I had this I - shoe sponsor
and there is this these cubbyholes whole
wall shoes and and and like the mess
thing something in my apartment she was
just going off and all these shoes were
sitting there like like tapping their
toes like okay throw away the drugs are
always impatiently tapping each other
kid through it's very fun my god and I'm
just watching it all this [ __ ] playing
okay wait a [ __ ] is that happening and
I'm thinking that's really crazy that's
what's happening and I'd look again like
yep champ it's still happening I totally
like like in any objects where the look
communicating to me and now they're
again you feel like in that situation
with the security camera that shoes are
moving correct high percent correct and
and and so it's a spiritual entities
ghost like whatever and like my dear
friends there were there were different
classifications of them there were
angels clearly angels that cared about
me living and they would even see in
there okay we were worried about you you
know like visually we've heard you're
killing yourself and it's not a can they
were very loving and and angel they they
were like rooting for me it's like
really what I prayed to you this day
like you know like when you go to rehab
and say you have to have a higher power
like you know like that I was like
whatever spun that [ __ ] chairs just I
pray to that you know something that
cares about me
so they're the angels then there were
demons for sure there were demons like
the voices would tell me like so I can
suffocate yourself to death is urging me
to kill myself and it was like super
dark entirely and scary and then and I
would probably classify this as demons
as well but much more funny like the
trickster spirits like [ __ ] they would
just [ __ ] entertain that same chair
that I was that I was in right like the
spinning office chair which was I had a
big dining room table like this the
computer set up at the TV on the wall
and that [ __ ] chair was in it just
caught [ __ ] fire engulfed in flames
and flames didn't hurt it's just they're
showing off like cool [ __ ] for me like
it's like whoa like whoa the check it
out like sure enough it's on fire the
whole [ __ ] chairs is on [ __ ] fire
I'm like whoa [ __ ] cool I just wanted
to do more drugs and power boards that's
why I classify these as demon spirits
because they just tricksters enabling
they wanted me I love it so all this is
cool this [ __ ] [ __ ] was so cool
there's so much of it like lights that
were never even there ever who just
flashing was a [ __ ] light show just
like bah bah bah bah the curtains are
opening and closing on their own the
whole place is going [ __ ] nuts and
I'm like woah this is a [ __ ] coolest
party ever like I just want to do more
drugs to keep the chin happening I had I
had this off and then scarier like I
loved it I loved it too much at certain
times it got scary there was a lot of
[ __ ] dark creepy scary [ __ ] that went
down to layer you by yourself usually
when I am going to hallways just you
know how hey there were there were a
couple times but but but the other
person if they were there they wouldn't
be tribute to it everybody like you know
there's like they're like rules for the
spirits but I had this song I know the
rules they're not they're not supposed
to interfere with it can't physically
like they can't they can't like
manipulate like like how the camera fear
with free will they can't like
manipulate things to alter the course
you know so really they've got those
rules you learn from interacting with
them
uh-huh and they weren't sources like
say anything they like and it's like the
committee and you can hear them kind of
you know but like and they're in another
thing but if you do enough drugs that's
why the same thing happens if you're on
meth as if you're on a Coke or even like
sometimes the alcohol like all roads
lead to the same place if you if you do
enough drugs and you [ __ ] yourself up
enough even PCB like that you erode the
the barriers between us and these
entities you know and and then you start
experiencing that's why I still believe
it's real dude and yeah I'd like some of
the other trickster [ __ ] was [ __ ]
bad-ass me I like that I had this at
this globe like the earth and and the
base of it I drilled to a skateboard and
then the skateboard I drilled to the
wall so the globe is coming out
protruding like this i sat there and
looked like I looked at [ __ ] cloud I
watched my own face like the Linkwood
Terminator in the globe like I can't
push him out
it came pushing out like the [ __ ]
globe and and my first came pushing out
and then started head bang the globe
boom I was like wow yeah Majan watching
the gnarly and watch that of you oh yeah
and I would make my own dad you know it
like I would not omit oh well yeah I
mean like guys exist you know yeah there
was a whole documentary that was made
about my downward spiral and psychosis
and ultimately to my own footage of you
like internet and and dude what the
footage reveals is me reacting to a lot
of this stuff that like having there not
ever you can tell like I'm like wow you
don't know yeah so I mean there's a
million that's a million [ __ ] things
okay so in in this world where these
spirits are real like what what is their
motivation what are they doing like on
the other side and white why is it so
compelling to them to come interact with
people on drugs I think it's the people
who are on drugs they have at a
receptive so what's an access to like
them
um they get like a signal they're like I
can talk to this person where they don't
have access
- like they're not everybody rags and
like I don't know man maybe I'm just out
my mind no on your I mean if I dread
personal experience right right right
right
my experience my belief and said ah is
it the barriers are guard
you know like for you you aren't aware
of them because he's got these barriers
in place which have not eroded right to
the point where you can become aware of
them sound there they're aware when your
barriers down uh-huh for sure got it and
that and once there when woodson
motivation I think the tricks or stuff
that just made me so hungry to keep that
[ __ ] happening I just want like this all
like just even the voice is everything
like the people walking around i watch
the [ __ ] dude come out like I last
time on in 2003 and yeah it was really
kind of a traumatic thing for me not
that I lost my mom but but the last five
years of her life were she was she
survived an aneurysm and and she was
very [ __ ] damaged like she is
physically and mentally horribly
disabled and had bedsores and it was
just [ __ ] terrible like she was in
great pain and her last five years were
traumatic and Netflix nimbala at one
point when when I was in this apartment
like Denman in mind [ __ ] psychosis I
want you to come out of the bathroom he
walked right behind me he stopped and
and as my interpretation went like that
right which I interpreted to be like he
stopped and so I can paid respect to my
mom and then turned II kept walking
through the apartment I watched this
[ __ ] dude pick up pick up the ball
pick his roll out smoke put it back and
then so I can walk through the wall
[ __ ] was never there dude
never there and you'll hear people who
have said coach to talk about shadow
people like I'm not talking about
there's a lot of shadow people too
but I'm talking about they were like
fully formed totally people picking up
actual objects rivers the spirit world
is real in the sense that you've
experienced it that's just so bizarre
like what are they
what are they what is the question if I
may in [ __ ] it like wouldn't like that
this this third dimensional experiences
so like minor dude and so like I read a
book and this is theory do you know
about junk DNA do you know that that for
the purpose of science for the we can
only our best scientific knowledge of
our own DNA indicates that we only use
10% of our brain and that the we can
only identify that there is any purpose
whatsoever to 10% of our DNA
leaving the scientific position of the
scientific community has the position
that 90% of our DNA they call it quote
junk DNA they do not know what it's for
and probably hurt like hereditary you
know from all the man I guess by were
usually been like billions of years of
evolution you know right but it's just
interesting that like to suggest that
here where this complex you know thing
and that ninety percent of what makes us
up has no purpose whatsoever and that is
just totally junk and for that matter
that 10 to 90 percent of our brain power
has no purpose whatsoever the resistance
we just have in laying around we're
never going to use it that is the theory
that I read which I have a pretty easy
time with and it's kind of it's a [ __ ]
up theory but that there are more
dimensions and that had that then we are
intended to be multi-dimensional beings
and that for us to use 100 percent of
our brain or firfer for 100 percent of
our DNA to be active that means that we
are simultaneously connected to the
versions of ourselves which are in other
dimensions right but the theory that I
read in this crazy book and adds this
might be a little far out there but but
I have an easier time believing this
then the
that I would believing that word junk
the junk DNA in theory that that the
earth is sort of a library so to speak
and a lot of you know I had like
information and such and it's very very
valuable in in the universe and all
dimensions you know and that the theory
is that some 300,000 years ago ownership
of the earth has switched right into the
new owners of Earth found that as
multi-dimensional beings which we used
to be a cordon of the area Scientology
should it's really it's really not to
tell me or whatever but the idea was
that we used to be fully
multi-dimensional but we were too
difficult to control interesting so so
the the this is this new like ownership
whatever they would basically went under
the hood and unplugged 90% of our DNA
which leaves us without us being plugged
in we don't know what the [ __ ] meaning
of life is we have no idea what our
purpose is and regard man like this kind
of like we're like a little bit don't
know why were you what's going away more
than me you know meets the eye or we
write or sieve that's all right we were
not what we're not plugged in anymore so
we don't get we look at the negative
Canada the connection to exact is the
evidence from is that we only use 10% of
our brain and building but like not only
10% 10% nah yeah that's fine I think
that we abandoned doesn't miss it was
living around I think I think that
they're having two percent of our brain
but just at different times I think
that's I don't know I want to effect
said let's do a mag check on John John
Vianney we do we use I'm more I'm almost
more more interested in the DNA I
haven't heard the junk DNA that is
fascinating
yeah jump in and ninety percent of our
DNA they have no [ __ ] idea what it's
for humans use 100 other brains despite
popular myth uh about college students
from believe me on his temper said well
this is just some dumbass website but
alright ensign I'm Way more concerned
with junk DNA but just for the record
because this was a really realistic
right they wonder yeah I believed it for
a long time and someone told me that
have been some kind of developments in
the scientific community regarding junk
DNA that are newer but still we don't
[ __ ] know don't talk about brain use
now let's look into their junk name yeah
be a dare DNA right and non-coding DNA
is what it's called and what good brand
is it's a total [ __ ] like is this a
[ __ ] controversial thing for a clean
and sober guy to say because like the
higher power is such a big part of the
recovery process you know fades and God
I think it's [ __ ] full-scale
arrogance to say that that you are your
atheist and then you're 100% sure there
is no God and I think it's all so
[ __ ] arrogant to say that you're a
hundred percent sure that there is I
think that we have limitations yeah we
have we have a [ __ ] limited [ __ ]
ability in our physical form completely
heaven and you know the woods like it
yeah I think that you're arrogant if
you're anything but agnostic so I think
I think the definition is to believe in
an octave I'm agnostic so I think people
misunderstand a theism well there is
that means I'm sure there is no God no
it's not it's not quite that that's the
misunderstanding of it but well these
are like fedora wearing like 15-year
olds
I'm very deep atheist I think atheism in
the true sense is that I don't god don't
believe in God because I've never been
given any reason or evidence to believe
in God I don't that's a nice definition
of an agnostic and I always used to say
that as oh I think I had no trouble
believing like I say I would say she's
really not to know I got it open to the
idea of God but I don't know I don't
know right that's where I fall but an
ATM is ATM is I don't believe in God
because I had a reason to believe in God
all right
I thought it's not like it is a
conviction that there is no God like I
think that though some media has
misrepresented atheism you're saying
atheist means that assuming there is a
God I'm pretty sure he wants his privacy
yeah that's me and eventually don't ya
what's that the founding fathers were
deistic and that means I think I my
favorite death metal band is D died so
deism is [ __ ] awesome and all the
founding fathers were into the [ __ ]
they're like there is a God he came he
created the University granted the earth
and then he [ __ ] off
my share about us he doesn't interact in
our lives at all he came he saw
conquered anything okay it's kind of
fascinating well I shouldn't think did
this is where what I would believe there
goes right back to the whole thing where
we're talking about with the spirits and
entities is that we are [ __ ] made it
is the same way that we make cars and
they run right the whole thing like
we're just a [ __ ] the human body is
like a [ __ ] it's like a toy car made
by like a spiritual entity on the Han
Solo I can't how about how about this
okay like the one strong argument for
not killing yourself is that when you
take the gun and when you pull the
trigger and he's [ __ ] dead the first
thing that happens is you're like why am
I still thinking you know like why am i
knowes and that's how can you confirm
this well you can't confirm it but but
my theory here is that that weird that
the brain is not a generator of
consciousness right it's not the it's
not the place where we're consciousness
that I think you're not is on it's not a
brain phone there's a brief agree the
brain does not generators I should say
the brain does not transmit the
consciousness rather to Glenn oh yeah
right my theory because if the brain is
a receiver of consciousness so as to say
that my thing so as to say there like
when you pulled it when you pull the
trigger and shoot your brain it's kind
of like taking a radio right you know
like Larry like this [ __ ] thing right
here right this iPad is not generating
that image it's receiving that event of
three sort of so if we take a hammer if
I take a hammer that [ __ ] smash this
iPad like right like like it just which
is the analogy for taking a gun a
machine in my head if I smashed this
iPad to smithereens my shoe or the gun
that [ __ ] and but have to go out
there so you're only you're not killing
the [ __ ] signal you're telling the
receiver that's called science and
that's the soul as soul is that is you
soul is what the signal that is being
picked up by the Supes even killed it
that's a nice thought I haven't thought
about that way yeah we killed us like a
receiver you haven't [ __ ] killed the
signal that's very dope and so now so
now what is the receiver the body the
brain right
it's a [ __ ] toy some is a toy in a
spaceship it
- toy like a [ __ ] like a toy car like
whatever the kind of things we make
except at the creator and there are like
the ultimate creator god they're [ __ ]
levels of the stairs at dimensions and
there's so much going on that we don't
know about and they're I hope so it's a
lot more interesting though is there are
creators that created us like [ __ ]
little vehicles it's like a [ __ ] car
we make a car we get in the car we drive
it around we're a [ __ ] car that was
made by a [ __ ] low-level [ __ ]
spirit creator and [ __ ] they're in the
car and they're driving around the me
car and so in that sense yeah our
creator [ __ ] laptop I still not
totally convinced of this idea of like a
create a crater right I do believe in
higher power like God is my sense of
like there's just something so in X book
about about existing at all sure it's
just overwhelmingly impossible to even
conceptualize like the thought of like
existence first non-existence it's weird
what in a philosophical sense much
easier to prove that we don't exist and
to prove that we do exist right but the
thought of like a creator or like
intelligent design I think is easy to
fall into that because the it's so hard
to conceptualize what evolution looks
like over billions of years right like a
trial and error on the micro level over
billions of years it's like it's pasta
it's very possible explanation for how
you start from a one cell organism up to
this sushi ellicott like we just can't
fathom that and the same way we can't
fathom a god because it's kind of just
nature I mean you know the universe is
like 12 billion years we've been [ __ ]
evolving for like 25% of the whole
history right the whole existence of the
universe right and I believe that we're
not I would they talk about ascension
and you know how it said it's like we're
just not plugged in I think I know I
hope so I always have always hoped that
there's more because it's way more
[ __ ] interesting than your dog and
and again like with the toilet guard the
charm right that's what you want to
believe it with the car analogy and I
like where they say where they say we're
not human beings have
a spiritual experience rather we are
spiritual beings having a human
experience
I realize yes I'd just like a little car
you know they and then the car [ __ ]
dies and the spirit when we win this
[ __ ] physical incarnation dies the
spirit gets out of the car and [ __ ]
gets in some other card that other car
might be a [ __ ] plant or you know
whatever whatever the case may be is for
sure but in Medinah looking for me I
don't doubt any of that dude did I think
that conviction is awesome
sometimes I wish I was more and isn't
there like pretty undeniable proof of
reincarnation all right well that's a
another big statement what is in your
opinion proof of reincarnation I like
that
like little two-year-old kids that have
memories and previous live and they just
blow it out about that dad think Google
undeniable proof of reincarnation here
we go looking it up going along yeah we
should we should cruise
let's lunch rappin that was by the way i
think the best ghost story
that [ __ ] was a gnarly go thank you
probably ranked that with this yeah I
love all that the help is honestly I
don't want chapter in my book called
angels and demons mmm fascinating not
really a minute let's wrap it up yeah oh
you're a legend thank you guys for
coming on today we really want you guys
know it was emotional roller coaster I
was glued it was a great time man I
really I love it
I think I enjoy being a guest on podcast
MO and then the idea of how to my own
pack I said it's a completely different
experience
yeah there's no obligation feel like I
can really like there's a lot but but
but with that Sena do need anybody who
is interested in my story to grab that
[ __ ] autographed book on my website
yep go support Stevo
well I didn't get my bird didn't get a
[ __ ] five-star rating because it's not
accept really yeah it's by definition
the most guaranteed great book you can
read by definition I named drop like a
mother's go to Stevo calm right to get
on cooking works like a god serious
there's little of there's little links
for all the social media and so I can
scope out the youtubes likes so
so media followers check him out he's on
the road doing standards right I don't
wait for your big show you're working on
I would love to have you guys there man
yeah yeah doing second I love you guys
man I love you man I can't believe it's
so surreal that's a real like yeah I was
watching everything in Israel even in
Israel how about you jackass all right
yeah yeah well that's that review was
huge and is ready now let's keep
stamping out the fakes let's stamp
amount let's get them let's I can you
know get people to just not gonna have
some integrity stop deceiving your
followers show respect to the people you
know who click your links what can you
do there's me you can never stop these
people because there's so much money
there's so much audience for it but at
least we can have a lot better right
yeah let's last release we can do let's
let's [ __ ] any blossom let's expose the
sake stay let's go cool thanks man for
coming on it was a great great time okay
thanks everyone for watching
oh yeah and like let me know if you've
been watching this [ __ ] and throw me
a tweet the road almost whoo yeah so um
I check it out I can check out my [ __ ]
mess at FIBO right at Stevo doesn't get
easier does not lot more to it throw me
it gives it a sponsor by fate oh what
fun yeah so means [ __ ] 22 guys thanks
for watching thank you love you we
appreciate you you guys and all next
Friday we have oh yeah it'll know where
it's filling though you guys were going
to freak out but we've been talking to
Jake Paul say messages every day bro
we've been maybe we might have Jake Paul
is he that it what is it sitting up
every day
yeah I actually have fake ball you mean
the guy who's got Kendrick Lamar just
running yeah right this [ __ ] very
worried about its career next I've loved
kids just another day Rob it's everyday
bro all right got it got it thanks for
watching guys yeah